Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, bis dahin, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
Ok, da bin ich, aber so wie es aussieht, ihr noch nicht.
Doch, das Small Access Point, der Name passt heute aber richtig gut, Alter.
Small Access Point.
Warte mal, ich glaube, ich habe die Musik ein bisschen laut.
Ah, Moment, Moment, Moment, Teams hat wieder am Sound rumgestellt.
Keck. Wait.
Warum macht Teams so Dinger?
Anzeige ist mehrfach. In Bearbeitung schon.
So, passt.
Benny, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Huge Subscriptions.
Borkchamp.
Moin, Ballstrikes. Ah, anscheinend ist heute Weeps in angesagt, ich sehe schon.
Ich habe heute Morgen schon, nicht, dass ich jetzt Mist erzähle, ich überlege gerade.
Ich glaube, acht Kilometer oder so, Berg rauf, Berg runter gelaufen, ich bin irgendwie ein bisschen im Arsch noch,
aber das macht nichts, und außerdem, vor allem, weil ich gerade richtig P-P-Po-Fat gefuttert habe.
Aber ich muss jetzt streamen, und ich habe gestern auch gesagt, heute gucken wir uns die neuen Access Points an.
Und wenn wir uns die angeguckt haben, dann kann ich über die nächsten Tage Unify bei mir rausschmeißen.
Da bin ich ehrlich gesagt ganz froh drüber.
Pausierungschamp. Moin, Renax. Renax? Renax?
Ich weiß nicht, wie man es genau ausspricht, aber du weißt ja, wer gemeint ist.
Ich muss mal kurz ein Update in meiner V-M machen. Aha, Bing Image of the Days, eine Windmühle, okay.
Gut zu wissen.
Wi-Fi 6, nein, kein Wi-Fi 6, weil mit Wi-Fi 6 über 1000 Euro und da habe ich keinen Bock drauf. Lul.
Erst mal Update machen. Warum kein Fan von Unify, weil es mir auf den Sack geht.
Wow. Alter, was ist mit den Unify-Updates bitte schön los gerade?
Okay, hat Manjaro wieder abgefuckt mit ihren Keys? Das habe ich auch schon mal hingekriegt.
Wobei, scheint okay zu sein.
Na gut, updaten wir mal.
Womit virtualisierst du das vor allem bei Workstation? Kann ich auch jedem nur empfehlen, vor allem bei Workstation ist es wirklich richtig poggy.
Also richtig nice.
Mir persönlich gefällt das deutlich besser als beispielsweise VirtualBox.
Zumindest für Desktop-Virtualisierung.
Im Server-Bereich kann man sich darüber streiten, was man da nimmt.
Da hat sicherlich auch sowas wie KVM oder meinetwegen noch Xen, Sutrix, sonstiges Gedöns.
Dann hat jemand von euch mal die Ehre und hat Red Hat Virtualis...
Wie heißt der Kram überhaupt?
Red Hat Virtualisation Server oder so verwenden müssen.
Das ist richtig eklig.
Das ist massiv, massiv eklig.
Ich musste das nur mal kurz mir angucken, das hat mir schon gereicht.
Killrock, ich habe keine Ahnung, was du meinst.
Also ja, vor allem bei Workstation kostet was, aber vor allem bei Workstation kriegst du relativ günstige Lizenzen schon.
Und Chet, ich weiß, man kriegt die Keys irgendwo anders auch, aber das will ich hier nicht promoten.
Also du kriegst beispielsweise sogar bei Amazon, selbst wenn du Amazon suchst, Forever Workstation Lizenzen.
Manchmal.
Aber ansonsten beim Keystore deiner Wahl kriegst du auch welche.
Also du musst keine 180 Euro oder was das normal kostet ausgeben.
Und ich finde, Forever Workstation hat die bessere Desktop Integration.
Virtualbox geht auch, aber gerade was 3D-Beschleunigung oder generell GPU-Beschleunigung in der VM angeht,
auch einfache Snapshot-Handling, generell von der Qualität, wie sich das anfühlt,
Desktop-Virtualisierung würde ich immer Forever Workstation vorziehen.
Im Server-Bereich gibt es bestimmt sogar Daseinsberechtigung für Hyper-V und solche komischen Konstrukte.
Wobei ich ehrlich gesagt, ganz im Ernst, wenn ich Server-seitig hauptsächlich virtualisieren müsste, würde ich Forever Workstation nehmen.
Würde ich auch ESX nehmen.
Oder aber im Heim-Bereich kann man natürlich auch so etwas wie Proxmox benutzen.
Oder eine Ubuntu-Server mit Wirt-Manager drauf.
Nein, Forever Workstation hat kein GPU-Pass-Through.
Das liegt daran, weil es halt oberhalb von Windows läuft.
Ich weiß, KVM kann das auch, aber KVM kann das nur, weil es Linux-only ist und es die passenden Module hat.
Das haben sie unser Windows noch nicht hinbekommen.
Leider, es wäre mega nice, könnte Forever Workstation.
Nicht, dass ich Mist erzähle und es hat sich mittlerweile geändert, aber ich bin mir relativ sicher, das geht nicht.
Was? Moment.
Nee, das ist nicht Support. Hätte mich jetzt auch sehr gewundert.
Ja.
Genau. Hätte mich jetzt nämlich auch gewundert, wenn sich da was geändert hätte.
Das ist tatsächlich ein Vorteil, wenn du Windows unter Linux virtualisierst mit KVM und GPU-Pass-Through.
Dafür hast du dann andere Probleme.
Du hattest mal gezeigt, ja, ich hab die bei so einer richtig ästlichen Seite gekauft, wo ich nie wieder was bestellen würde, weil die so shady aussieht, will ich jetzt nicht zeigen.
Ja, ESXi kann Pass-Through, ESXi läuft aber nicht unter Windows.
ESXi ist sein eigenes Betriebssystem.
Das ist ja auch der große Unterschied dazwischen.
Das ist quasi on top of Windows und das ist quasi unten drunter und du hast dann dein Windows vielleicht oder dein Linux in der VM.
Das kann das. Das ist halt tatsächlich cool, wenn du KVM unter Linux verwendest, dass die das halt auch im laufenden System können, was du sonst verwendest.
Auf der anderen Seite, ganz im Ernst, GPU-Pass-Through ist eh nicht so das Allergeilste, gerade wenn du den Bildschirm dann nicht mehr vom Desktop verwenden kannst.
Was du natürlich machen kannst, wofür es halt echt nice ist, die ganzen Grafikkarten, die haben ja auch Hardware-Video-Decoder.
Und das wäre natürlich sehr praktisch, weil, ich zeige euch das mal, wir machen jetzt mal Hardtop auf und ich gehe mal hier beispielsweise auf YouTube.
Und mache mal ein Video von mir auf.
Okay, das liegt jetzt, weil ich geupdatet habe, ist ein bisschen lahm, gerade bis ich neu gestartet habe.
So, jetzt mache ich mal mein Video an.
Oder ich schiebe mal kurz hier das Terminal rüber.
Machen wir mal ein Video an und schalten wir mal wirklich ordentlich hoch, 1080p.
Da sieht man halt schon, der braucht ganz gut CPU.
Warum braucht der gut CPU? Und der braucht übrigens umso mehr CPU, umso größer das Ganze hier wird.
Warum braucht der viel CPU?
Eier logisch.
Der braucht viel CPU, weil das Ding komplett CPU-decoded wird.
Vor allem bei Workstations oder Linux, nein, die verwenden kein KVM.
Die verwenden ihren eigenen Krämpel.
Das wäre tatsächlich so einer der wenigen Gründe, warum ich sagen würde, eine Grafikkarte irgendwie durchgereicht in die VM wäre cool,
weil ein Hardware-Video-Decoder macht den Browser an vielen Stellen oder generell auch Grafikkarten, macht den Browser und das Surfen um ein Vielfaches schneller.
Aber ansonsten, natürlich kannst du das auslagern.
Das ist doch das, was normalerweise passiert.
Schau mal, das geht jetzt nicht, weil ich hier keine Grafikkarte in der VM habe.
Oder zumindest keine richtige Grafikkarte, sondern nur so eine Fake-Grafikkarte.
Guck mal, wenn du hier guckst in Detail oder wo auch immer man Performance sieht, man sieht glaube ich nicht.
Ach du Scheiße, Wind aus Ansicht. Zumindest.
Wir nehmen jetzt mal Chromium und gehen mal auf YouTube.
Da wirst du sehen, das ist wahrscheinlich relativ...
Unter Ubuntu, ja unter Linux wird es ein bisschen schwieriger.
Unter Linux geht es mittlerweile auch ganz gut, aber da brauchst du die richtige Kombination aus Browser, Mesa, Treibern, also die richtigen Versionen, richtige Kernversion.
Ganz ehrlich, GPU-Decoding von Videos unter Linux ist so ein Ding.
Das geht, aber es müssen so die Sterne im richtigen Winkel stehen, dass das klappt.
So, aber unter Windows ist das seit Jahren ja schon so.
So, wenn ich jetzt hier hingehe, wird man sehen, das braucht relativ viel CPU-Lust, mein Chromium.
Relativ, geht so.
Aber wenn ich das Gleiche mal nehme und gehe in den echten Chrome und starte das gleiche Video.
Ja, Max halt mal die Klappe.
Und jetzt werdet ihr sehen, das Ding braucht nichts.
Guck mal.
Ja, ok.
Ähnlich, ähnlich viel.
Also aber im Vergleich zu meiner Linux-Kiste nichts.
Und man sieht auch, dass hier die GPU ganz gut dabei ist.
Unter Linux habe ich 80% CPU-Lust, hier plus 13.
Also das wäre schon cool, wenn man irgendwie aus diesen Gründen eine Grafika mit Workstation durchschleifen konnte.
Aber geht nicht.
Und ganz ehrlich, so essenziell ist es auch nicht, weil ich gucke im Endeffekt kaum so gut wie keine Videos in der VM.
Gut, also hätten wir das erledigt.
Ja, also warum kein Fan mehr von Unity, äh nicht von Uni-Fi.
Uni-Fi, nicht Unity.
Ok, also das muss ich heute wahrscheinlich öfters beantworten, deswegen sage ich das gleich mal am Anfang.
Ich habe es gestern ja auch schon erzählt.
Also es gibt ein großes Feature, wo ich echt enttäuscht bin von Uni-Fi, oder von Ubiquity, dass sie das nach Jahren immer noch nicht unterstützen.
Das hätte ich gerne, aber es kommen noch ein paar andere Sachen dabei, die ich auch nicht schön finde.
Also das erste ist, dass ich mit der generellen Qualität der Access Points nicht so wirklich zufrieden bin.
Ich habe teilweise Verbindungsabbrüche, unerklärlich, man weiß nicht genau warum.
Und ich habe auch schon so ziemlich alles optimiert, was du an Optimierung machen kannst.
Ich habe die Channel manuell verteilt, ich habe die Uni-Fi Optimierung ausgeschaltet.
Ich habe die Position der Access Points, ich habe die Sendeleistung runter gedreht, dass man sie so gut wie gar nicht mehr überschneidet.
Aber trotzdem, gerade bei dem, auf der Außenseite voraus, habe ich öfters mal Verbindungsabbrüche, keine Ahnung warum.
Aber damit könnte ich im Endeffekt noch leben.
Der nächste Punkt ist, also wir arbeiten uns jetzt mal so ein bisschen vor von den Punkten, die ich nervig finde, bis zu denen, die ich richtig kacke finde, dass es sie nicht gibt.
Das nächste ist der Uni-Fi Controller. Ich bin nie warm geworden mit dem Ding.
Ich habe prinzipiell nichts dagegen, dass man einen Controller braucht, aber ich mag den Uni-Fi Controller nicht.
Erstens finde ich die Settings da drinnen verwirrend.
Außerdem haben sie viele Auto-Optimierungen, die mir auf den Kicks gehen.
Die kann man sich umwegen, die sich bei jeder Version ändern, irgendwie ein- und ausstellen.
Aber viele Dinge im Uni-Fi Controller sind, finde ich, wie soll ich sagen, nicht griffig benannt.
Das ist so, als möchte Ubiquiti da so auf zwei Hochzeiten tanzen.
Auf der einen Seite möchte man sich quasi an so etwas höherpreisige Heim-Anwender richten und benennt deswegen die Sachen, sagen wir mal, easy.
Auf der anderen Seite möchte man sich eben an Leute richten, die ein bisschen mehr machen wollen, aber gerade da würde es helfen, wenn man die Dinge eben ordentlich benennt.
Ich bin kein Fan vom Uni-Fi Controller und das, was mich da eigentlich am meisten an dem Controller aufregt, ist,
ich habe den ja auf dem Raspberry Pi laufen, dass er mir schon nach zwei Updates mal nicht mehr gestartet ist,
bei dem einmal hat er irgendwelche Schmerzen gehabt mit der Java-Version
und dann hat er noch irgendwelche Schmerzen gehabt mit, glaube ich, übrig gebliebenen Zertifikaten von der Vorgänger.
Keine Ahnung, fragt mich nicht. Ich konnte das alles fixen, aber abfuck.
Und was mich aber am meisten nervt an dem Controller bzw. an dem, wie das bei Uni-Fi funktioniert,
in Verbindung mit dem Controller ist, dass wenn du einen WLAN hast, wenn du einen WLAN eingerichtet hast,
beispielsweise einen Test-WLAN und du aktivierst das wieder, dann muss jeder Axis-Point rebooten.
Das allein wäre ja gar nicht so extrem schlimm.
Das Dumme ist nur, dass das teilweise ewig dauert.
Also es braucht 40 Sekunden und bis zu einer Minute, teilweise bis die Axis-Points wieder richtig erreichbar sind,
bei so einem Reprovisioning, dann connecten sich natürlich alle WLAN-Geräte im Haus neu
zu unterschiedlichen Axis-Points, weil die unterschiedlich schnell booten und unterschiedlich schnell wieder hochkommen,
es sei denn, du pinst explizit deine Geräte, was dann auch fragwürdig ist bei manchen, also gerade bei Smartphones.
Dann dauert das wieder zwei Tage, bis sich das eingependelt hat und alles wieder an seinem richtigen Axis-Point hängt.
Das ist nervig. Also dieses ewige Rom-Reboote geht mir wirklich mega auf den Sack.
Dann habe ich noch das Problem, dass die nur so ganz merkwürdig das PoE unterstützt haben.
Eine Zeit lang, mittlerweile unterstützen die schninknormales, fragt mich nicht, 802.11ARF oder was ist der PoE-Standard?
802.3ARF links.
Ursprünglich hatten die mal Probleme und gingen nur mit ihrem komischen eigenen Injector, aber sei es drum.
So und das eigentliche Feature, was mir persönlich fehlt ist, warum ich mir jetzt auch zwei Axis-Points noch von eBay geholt habe ist,
ich möchte eigene Passwörter pro Gerät vergeben für das WLAN. Warum?
Weil ich habe ein Gäste-WLAN, ich habe ein normales Geräte-WLAN und ich habe ein IoT-WLAN.
Das IoT-WLAN hat für jedes Gerät das gleiche Passwort und das finde ich kacke.
Da gibt es Möglichkeiten, so gut wie jeder andere Hersteller kann das.
Ich rede jetzt nicht von WPA Enterprise wohlgemerkt, weil IoT-Geräte, die können kein WPA Enterprise.
TP-Link-Omada kann das auch mittlerweile, seit März können die das aber erst.
So und das ist doof und das ist ein Feature gerade für Leute, die viel IoT-Geräte haben, was tatsächlich fehlt.
Und UniFi hat schon Feature-Requests seit Jahren offen.
Es gibt sogar Leute, die haben das selbst nachgebaut, aber das kannst du halt komplett knicken, das willst du nicht haben.
Remember your duo Thunder? Yes, that's I think about 10 years ago.
Good Call of Duty Times.
Must be around Modern Warfare 2 or Black Ops 1?
Das war geil Leute, da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
So was wollte ich jetzt sagen? Genau, also es gibt ja Leute, die haben das versucht nachzubauen.
Das mit dem IoT geht mittlerweile über UID, das ist jetzt sehr random, das musst du mir ein bisschen genauer erklären, was du damit meinst.
Also gerade für UniFi habe ich nichts gefunden in dieser Richtung und mich würde es hart wundern, wenn es das gibt.
Weil die Diskussion, dass es nicht gibt und UniFi das nicht einbauen will, sind gerade mal 2-3 Wochen alt.
Zumindest haben Leute nachgebaut.
Ja gut, da brauchst du noch irgendeinen extra Router oder so von UniFi dabei.
Das ist ja natürlich bescheuert, dass man das beknackt, warum geht sowas nicht über den Controller?
Aber wir gucken uns das mal kurz an, was wir da haben.
Ich werde mir garantiert keine Dream Machine daheim mehr hinstellen, das kannst du knicken, aber wir gucken uns das Ganze mal an.
Getting Started
UniFi Identification Early Access
Chillfreak, das machen wir heute.
Ok, das muss man uns klar machen, also UID ist eine Identity as a Service.
Alter, die Abkürzungen werden echt immer hängen geblieben, oder?
Kegway, Mann.
Ah Gott.
IDAS
IDAS, gut.
Cloud-Based Identity Aut... Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Das ist was anderes.
Das ist was anderes, was... Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Das ist nicht das, was ich meine.
Edit, Remove Users Quickly, Secure, Manage User Access Anyway.
Connect, Verify, Registered Users, Devices, Services...
Das klingt mir eher nach irgendeinem WPA Enterprise Geschichte.
Nicht nach normalem WPA Pre-Shared Key.
Achso, UID is currently supported in United States and Canada. Ok, hat sich das ja mit der schon mal erledigt.
Da müssen wir jetzt mal schauen, inwieweit sich das vergleichen lässt.
Aber für mich sieht das aus, als sind das zwei unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe.
Alter, was, was, was... Nee, nee, nee, ganz bestimmt.
Im Leben nicht, im Leben nicht.
Werde ich mir sowas holen.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Das scheint mir was gänzlich anderes zu sein.
Aber wir können uns ja mal kurz das Video zu angucken.
Ich soll noch lauter machen, weil die ihren Sound nicht im Griff haben.
Ah, wo ist mein Sound?
Da.
Nee, nee, nee, das ist nicht... Das geht in die ganz andere Richtung.
Das ist eher sowas wie Zero Ors oder so. Irgend so einen globalen Identity Service.
Das ist, glaube ich, ganz was anderes.
Nee, nee.
Nee, nee, nee, das war was anderes.
Ja, okay. Nee, nee, das war was anderes.
Wie gesagt, es ist auch das Geheule schon seit Jahren groß, dass das UniFi nicht implementiert.
Und das ist der Hauptgrund, den ich haben will, warum ich was anderes haben will.
Ich habe saumäßig viele IoT-Geräte am Start.
Wir haben letztens in mein DHCP geguckt.
Ich hatte in den letzten paar Monaten oder sagen wir so die letzten zwei, drei Jahre 85 Geräte im WLAN.
Oder 75. Ich weiß nicht, 85 oder 75.
Und davon sind natürlich nicht mal alle an.
Aber daran sieht man es ja schon.
Wenn man IoT-Geräte wegschmeißt, schmeißt man sein WLAN-Passwort in den Müll.
Und das finde ich doof.
Deswegen finde ich diese Variante, was andere Hersteller haben,
dass du WLAN-Passwörter vergeben kannst pro Gerät.
Eine super Geschichte.
Wie gesagt, WPA Enterprise ist was anderes.
Das muss das Endgerät unterstützen.
Hier geht es darum, dass billige WLAN-Steckdosen ein eigenes Passwort bekommen können für das gleiche WLAN.
Wo ist meine?
Jetzt drüber ist es kalt.
Kennt ihr meinen guten Channel, der gleich wo man gut C lernen kann?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich habe mir keine C-Tutorials auf YouTube angeguckt bisher.
Nee, die VM kann nicht auf die GPU zugreifen.
Die VM hat eine eigene GPU, also eine virtualisierte GPU,
die mittlerweile, und das sollte man auch machen,
du kannst in den VMware-Settings eigentlich in den Häkchen machen.
Bei Display kannst du sagen Accelerate 3D Graphics.
Das ist ganz praktisch.
Dann kann das Ding sogar OpenGL und in etwas älteres DirectX unter Windows.
Das bringt schon einiges, aber ist natürlich nicht damit zu vergleichen mit einer durchgereichten Grafikkarte.
Und leider können die keine Video-Decoder durchreichen.
Ja, ich auch. Dafür habe ich zum größten Teil.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, was die da...
Ja, also welche Access Points habe ich mir jetzt gekauft?
Also ich habe ja tatsächlich das letzte Mal ein bisschen geliebeäugelt,
wobei ich muss da gar nicht auf eBay,
ein bisschen geliebeäugelt, ob ich mal das TP-Link Zeug nicht mal antesten soll.
Aber ich habe mir jetzt gedacht, wir machen was anderes,
und zwar ich habe mir zum Testen einen etwas älteren hiervon gekauft.
Die sehen so aus, mit dem werden wir das heute auch ein bisschen ausprobieren, so ein Teil.
Das ist die vorletzte Generation.
Also sprich, das ist 802 11 AC Wave 1. Ach, frag mich nicht.
Ist nicht das Schnellste, ist auch nicht mehr so ported, ist End of Life mittlerweile bei denen.
Aber zum Testen ist das ganz gutes Ding.
Und zum wirklich Betreiben habe ich mir relativ günstig auf eBay so einen, Moment, so einen bekommen,
für 260 Euro oder sowas, 72 Euro irgendwie so in dem Dreh.
Die Dinger kosten neu 1300, das ist ein fucking Access Point, für 1367 Euro.
Das ist viel, viel zu teuer, würde ich niemals neu kaufen.
Und die neuen von denen, die bewegen sich tatsächlich in diesen Preisregionen.
Also wenn man sich beispielsweise einen AX kaufen will, auch 1000 Euro in dem Dreh.
Also das sind die Allerneuesten mit Wi-Fi 6, also 802 11 AX.
Also das, was umgangssprachlich so unter Wi-Fi 6 läuft.
Was ich übrigens der Big Brain von dieser Wi-Fi Alliance finde, dass sie das Wi-Fi 6 genannt haben.
Beziehungsweise sie haben mit Wi-Fi 5 schon angefangen.
Jetzt mit Wi-Fi 6, die machen das richtig.
Die USB Leute benennen ihren USB-Kram unsinnig, sodass es kein Sau versteht.
Und die sind schlau bei der Wi-Fi Alliance, die haben gesagt, kein Noob.
Checkt, IEEE 802.11 AX.
Und daraufhin hat man gesagt, man nennt es einfach Wi-Fi 6.
Das ist eigentlich das Beste, was man machen konnte.
Das ist ein griffischer Marketingbegriff im Endeffekt, wo die Leute was mit anfangen können.
Sehr schön, ja.
So, das sind die ganz neuen.
Und die Dinger sind halt saumäßig teuer.
Deswegen habe ich mir auf Ebay so einen bestellt.
Die haben auch noch aktuelle Firmware, obwohl sie offiziell, glaube ich, nicht mehr hergestellt werden.
Und es ist für mich daheim sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr,
sehr offiziell, glaube ich, nicht mehr hergestellt werden.
Und es ist für mich daheim, hoffe ich mal, möglich, wenn ich den in Flur hänge,
dass ich das ganze Haus inklusive Terrasse damit abdecke mit einem Access Point.
Ich komme damit vielleicht nicht mehr so weit in Garten rein wie mit dem UniFi Zeug.
Aber ganz ehrlich, im Garten schalte ich dann einfach oder switchte das Smartphone dann halt auf mobile.
Ja, dass ich aus dem Garten nicht auf irgendwelche internen Sachen zugreifen kann, soll mir recht sein.
Und ich habe dann Features, die ich haben will und insgesamt auch einen besseren Access Point.
So, den habe ich mir gekauft. Also ich habe mir einen R600 gekauft, einen R710. Den R710 probiere ich im Offstream aus.
Ja, heute basteln wir mit dem R600 rum.
Können Sie was trinken?
Ich glaube, ich habe zu lange gelabert, dass man das klippen könnte.
Nein, ich kaufe mir keinen Access Point für 1300. Ich habe doch gerade gesagt,
ich habe mir den für 270 Euro bei eBay gekauft, der braucht.
Also die Dinger finde ich nice, gerade das, was ich gesehen habe.
Bin ein bisschen hinten dran. Also wie gesagt, wir haben mal nachgeguckt, das ist was anderes.
Ja, ich verstehe generell nicht, warum die Leute teilweise so scharf drauf sind, alles über die Cloud zu machen.
Gerade wenn man dann so Sachen mitbekommt wie für Smart Home Geräte, wo Hersteller komplett den Betrieb eingestellt haben
und die Geräte gar nicht mehr funktionieren. Wie hießen die? Insteon oder so?
Home, was Home Assistant jetzt übernommen hat. Insteon, genau.
So, die haben einfach, April 2022 sind die quasi pleite gegangen oder so, haben ihre Cloud abgeschaltet
und alle Leute, die sich Geräte von denen gekauft haben, waren erstmal, wie sagt man, so schön heutzutage gefickt.
Die konnten erstmal nichts machen. Also deswegen verstehe ich das nicht.
Oder es gab doch auch schon öfters Probleme, ich kann mich noch dran erinnern von zwei Jahren,
wo AWS mal geruckelt hat, so paar Stunden lang, dass dann manche Leute, die smarte Thermostat da hatten,
noch nicht mehr ihre Heizung bedienen konnten. Da hört es bei mir auf.
Also ganz ehrlich, wenn ich eine Internetanbindung und eine funktionierende Hersteller Cloud brauche,
dass meine Heizung geht, dann ist irgendwas verkehrt.
April, ach stimmt, vielleicht war das nur ein April-Scherz. Aber der April ist ja vorbei.
Und die sind immer noch weg.
Blu Media sagt, er findet Unifis vom Low Budget Enterprise zum typischen Prozoomer-Crap montiert.
Bin mittlerweile Fan von... Ja, das umschreibt es eigentlich ganz gut.
Ohne Scheiß, der Omada-Controller. Ich hab mir das letztens mal angeguckt, die Oberfläche.
Also das inspiriert von Unifi zu nennen, ist schon fast eine maßlose Untertreibung.
Also das ist eins zu eins copy-pasted von Unifi. Teilweise das Omada-UI.
Aber soll mir recht sein im Endeffekt. Was juckt es mich als User, ja?
Wie gesagt, ich hab mir zwei Exist-Points geholt, ein R600 zum Heute-Ausprobieren und ein R710 zum Daheimverwenden.
Ja, Grip, Windows 11.
Zurück kann ich nichts zu sagen, hatte ich noch nie.
Ja, das Gute an den Dingern ist, die haben nicht nur coole Funktionen, leider haben die halt so die übliche Geschichte,
die viele Enterprise-Anbieter haben, so nach dem Motto, kauft ihr doch eine Lizenz für unseren Controller,
für 150 Euro im Monat oder was auch immer.
Nein, kein Dell R710, einen Exist-Point.
Und aber auch nicht für den Preis, sondern von Ebay gebraucht.
Die Bildqualität von den Dingern soll halt mega nice sein.
Ich persönlich kann es nicht beurteilen, also ich hab weder in meine Unifi Exist-Points reingeguckt selber,
noch hab ich in den R710 reingeguckt, ich hab aber Tierdowns gesehen und die Einschätzung von Leuten dazu gelesen
und von der Bildqualität sollen die Dinger wirklich mega nice sein.
Unifi Dinger halt preislich angemessen, was man da bekommt.
Also im Prinzip kann man sich das so vorstellen, in den Unifi, in beiden ist quasi ein besserer Kleiderbügel drin als Antenne.
Nur, dass die anderen halt wohl deutlich besser isoliert sind und ein, wie nennen sie das,
ein proprietäres Beamforming haben, dass der Exist-Point quasi in Richtung, ich nenne es mal easy,
in Richtung der Geräte funkt, mit denen er kommunizieren will.
Also, ob ich ein EU-Gerät gekauft habe, ja und nein, ich habe ein US-Gerät gekauft und ein EU-Gerät.
Das heißt, wir müssen jetzt gleich das US-Gerät noch country unlocken.
Aber Spoiler, das hab ich schon mal gemacht vorm Stream und das funktioniert.
Also wir machen das gleich noch mal zusammen im Stream, da kann ich euch nämlich zeigen, wie das funktioniert.
Man kann US-Geräte kaufen und sie country unlocken. Das funktioniert, ich hab's ausgedreht.
Aber das machen wir gleich noch mal zusammen.
Normalerweise ist es nämlich so, dass US-Geräte gar nicht für den Export gedacht sind,
dass man eigentlich US-Geräte nur im Kocona Freedom Land betreiben kann oder betreiben soll
und es dann auch von den Frequenzen und der Sendeleistung und so gar nicht konform ist für Deutschland.
Dementsprechend ist es doppelt blöd, eigentlich US-Geräte zu kaufen, aber in dem Fall ist es gut.
Es gibt hier beispielsweise eine GitHub-Seite, die das erklärt, wie das funktioniert.
Das werden wir gleich machen, wir werden gleich das hier machen, bzw. das da, Obtain Route Shell.
Dazu müssen wir erstmal die Firmware downcrate, uns Route-Rechte besorgen, dann das country unlocken.
Wie gesagt, ich hab das im Vorfeld schon ausgedreht, das funktioniert, aber wir machen es trotzdem gleich noch mal zusammen.
Access Point und gleich Router, in der Regel, also sagen wir mal so, da sind zwei unterschiedliche Funktionen.
Es ist oftmals so, dass Geräte ein bisschen beides können.
Ja, bestes Beispiel ist die Fritzbox dafür, die hat ja nicht nur Router und Access Point,
die hat ja auch noch Deck-Server, billig, nass und tausende andere Funktionen, DVBC-Tuner, alle tausende Funktionen eingebaut.
Und an Access Point gibt es bestimmt auch genug, die routen können zwischen Interface und dem WLAN in Letzberg.
Also ich denke mal, das überschneidet sich zum größten, aber es sind auf jeden Fall zwei komplett getrennte Funktionen.
Ja, Access Point ist quasi für Layer 1 und 2, könnte man so sagen, also quasi für die Übertragung über die Luft per Funk.
Und für die Kommunikation zwischen auf Layer 2 Ebene, also auf das, was dann quasi WLAN ist.
Und dann solche Sachen, wie von einem Netz ins andere Netz kommen, dann brauchst du einen Router für.
Wäre es sinnvoll, einen Standalone-Router zu holen oder eine Kombi, das kommt darauf an, was du machen willst.
Die meisten Leute kommen ohne Probleme hin mit einer publischen Fritzbox daheim, die alles in einem Gerät macht.
Tja, ich weiß es nicht. Ich verstehe eh nicht so genau, was das USB-Konsortium da treibt.
Das könnte ich wahrscheinlich machen, ja, das ist richtig. Wahrscheinlich, du hast Recht, wahrscheinlich könnte ich die alten Access Points irgendwie als...
Aber das werde ich wahrscheinlich nicht machen. Was, warum lecke ich Critical Information?
Wie gesagt, kein Unify mehr habe ich gerade ausführlich erklärt, ganz kurz für alle Leute, die jetzt noch dabei gekommen sind.
Also aktuell habe ich Unify am Start mit 4 Access Points, Erdgeschoss, Keller, Erster Stock und dann ein Raus, Gartenterrasse.
Mir fehlen Features, die ich gerne hätte, wo Unify keinen Bock hat, die darauf einzubauen, wo seit Jahren schon Feature-Requests und Sachen auf sind,
die alle anderen Hersteller in etwas höher preisigen Segmenten können und auch günstigere können, auch Newcomer können, wo Unify keinen Bock drauf hat.
Außerdem habe ich Connection-Probleme mit einem der Access Points und ich bin auch kein großer Fan des Unify-Controllers.
Aber hauptsächlich fehlen mir Features für meine IoT-Geräte, die ich unbedingt haben will und Unify keinen Bock drauf hat.
Ja, die Dinger sind... Deswegen bin ich letztendlich auch bei dem Hersteller gelandet, weil egal wo du guckst,
natürlich wird sich drüber beschwert, dass die komische Lizenz-Praktiken haben und sowas, wer hat das im Enterprise-Umfeld nicht,
aber dass Bild-Quality und die generelle Qualität der Access Points wirklich mit das Beste sein muss, was es gibt.
Also quasi... Wie sagt man so? Der Benchmark? Nee, keine Ahnung.
Also sogar so, dass halt sogar Cisco-Fans sagen, hey, ich verwende mittlerweile lieber diesen Hersteller als Cisco selbst.
Also da scheint schon was dran zu sein. Ich habe da eine ganze Weile auf Reddit gelesen, in verschiedenen Netzwerken,
Subreddits und Admin-Subreddits, was zu den unterschiedlichen Herstellern.
Habe mir auch die Features ein bisschen verglichen, wer was kann.
Leider können halt viele Hersteller interessante Features nur mit Cloud-Anbindung oder besser gesagt,
die günstigeren Geräte, die man halbwegs erschwinglich bekommt, sind nur die mit Cloud-Anbindung.
Oder man braucht irgendeinen Controller, der dann irgendwie 2000 Euro im Jahr kostet.
Das wollte ich alles nicht haben. Und diese Ruckus-Dinger kann man Standalone ohne Controller betreiben,
mit allen wichtigen Features, die ich haben will. Und die sollen halt auch eine wirklich gute Qualität haben vom Gerät selber.
Das werden wir heute mal ausprobieren.
Wohlgemerkt nicht mit einem R750, weil ein R750 kostet auch wieder, keine Ahnung, 1500 Euro oder so.
Ja, ein Schnapper, 1500 Euro Access Point. Also der muss ja auch gut sein für den Preis,
ansonsten wird das keiner kaufen. Das habe ich nicht. Wie gesagt, ich habe einen R600 zum Testen und einen R710.
Das ist quasi der Vorgänger, gab es noch einen R720, kann sein. Also ich habe quasi Last-Gen.
Das ist Current-Gen, ich habe Last-Gen. Dafür kostet Last-Gen,
quasi nur ein Achtel vom Preis her auf Ebay und ist für daheim vollkommen ausreichend.
Ja, die sind nicht Insdeon, die sind Insdeoff. Richtig.
Ja, nice.
Ja, mein R600, den ich zum Testen gekauft habe, der bekommt keine Updates mehr, aber das macht ja nichts.
Entity Framework, ja, geht so. Kenne ich mich halbwegs brauchbar mit aus.
Aber Entity Framework Core, also nicht.NET 4.8, EF6 oder so.
Wenn ich eine Cloud für meine Heizen bräuchte, hätte ich echt Probleme,
mein Internet verabschiedet sich. Ja, ist so.
Wie gesagt, wir flashen das gleich um. Hast du schon mal OPC UA Server? Nein, keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Kommt drauf an, in 2,4 Gigahertz Band gibt es glaube ich nur, gibt es denn für Channels, die sich nicht überlagern?
Sechs Channels oder irgendwie sowas?
In 5 Gigahertz gibt es mehr.
Und in 5 Gigahertz gibt es noch mehr Channels, die sich nicht überlagern.
Aber ich glaube, es gibt noch mehr Channels, die sich nicht überlagern.
In 5 Gigahertz gibt es mehr. Und das ist auch pro Land unterschiedlich.
Oder so, genau. Und die überschneiden sich ja auch.
Also im Prinzip hast du ja 1 bis 14, wobei 14 keine, die verwenden keine bis 11, du hast 1 bis 11, genau.
Bei uns ist glaube ich auch so, dass man das nicht...
Also ich kann auch glaube ich nur bis 11 auswählen.
Und die überschneiden sich auch soweit, dass es im Endeffekt genau, dass es im Endeffekt quasi 1,6 und 11 gibt.
Wenn du wirklich willst, dass sich nichts überschneiden, also genau 1,6 und 11.
Also du hast quasi 3 Channels für 2,4. Bei dem anderen hast du noch ein bisschen mehr.
Bei 5 Gigahertz.
Da musst du jetzt gucken, wie das beispielsweise in Deutschland ist, weil das ja auch nicht in allen Ländern gleich ist.
Wann kommt der Nachfolger von 5 Gigahertz eigentlich für Wi-Fi?
Die Frequenz hat nicht unbedingt was mit dem Wi-Fi-Standard zu tun.
Also die ersten, keine Ahnung, 5,6 Wi-Fi-Standards waren alle auf 2,4 Gigahertz.
Dann gab es irgendwann noch 5 Gigahertz dazu.
Und jetzt ist man am Überlegen, ob nicht noch irgendwie mal irgendwann 6 Gigahertz dabei kommt.
Aber das macht ja auch nichts.
Also du kannst ja auch im 5 Gigahertz Bereich ohne Probleme neue Techniken verwenden.
Ja genau, das kommt jetzt dabei.
Wie gesagt, 2,4 und 5 gibt es ja weiter und nur weil ein neues Frequenzband dazukommt, heißt es nicht, dass es irgendwie ein neuer WLAN-Standard nicht auch was bringen würde für die alten Frequenzen.
Ja gerade so Sachen wie Beamforming, wo sie jetzt auch bei Wi-Fi 6 glaube ich viel gemacht haben.
Also dass du quasi ein bisschen besser in Richtung des Geräts funken kannst, was das haben will.
Das ist schon eine coole Geschichte.
Ja komm, also Wi-Fi 6e ist ja nur wirklich noch ganz neu.
Du hast doch kaum Geräte, die das unterstützen.
Du hast jetzt die ersten Hooter, die gab es aber schon bevor das überhaupt standardisiert ist.
Das ist wirklich sehr, sehr neu.
Da gibt es auch schon Wikipedia Eintracht dazu.
Oh, es gibt noch nicht mal, doch es gibt einen Wikipedia Eintracht dazu.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was man da aktuell welche, keine Ahnung, ob überhaupt aktuelle Smartphones schon 6e unterstützen.
Also das ist wirklich ganz, ganz neu.
So, gut, haben wir das geklärt.
Erzähl was du wissen willst wegen Entity Framework.
Okay, also wir haben geupdatet.
Browser, update, ich reboote mal kurz, mach nochmal hier ein Update und dann fangen wir an.
Also wie gesagt, für den Test heute verwenden wir den hier.
Den habe ich mir extra bestellt.
Okay, ich mache es nachher auf.
Visual Studio, aktualisieren, alles klar.
Okay, Moment, was kann ich?
JS 60, JS 68, Linux, nein, Linux Latest.
Soll ich das wirklich aninstallen?
Ich bin wieder, aber warum habe ich denn wieder Treiber?
Okay, Reise FS brauchen wir nur wirklich nicht mehr.
Sekunde Leute, die Musik nervt mich.
Ich muss mal etwas entspannenderes anmachen.
Wollen wir da, ja das ist gut hier.
Exzellent.
Du du du du du du du du du du du.
J-Law, moin.
Massive Passwort, Massive Passwort, kommt hier einer drauf hier auf mein Passwort?
Äh, hallo?
Soll ich Linux Latest deinstallieren, ist das wirklich so eine gute Idee?
Mal gucken, welchen Kernel ich habe.
Nicht, dass ich jetzt irgendwie was gelöscht habe.
Äh, installed, recommended, so einen alten Kernel.
Was, was habe ich denn hier für einen uralt Kernel drauf?
Monkey?
Was ist das denn?
Was habe ich denn hier für einen uralt Kernel drauf?
Monkey S, was ist das denn?
Yes, LTS, recommended, LTS.
Na zumindest mal eine LTS Version können wir mal upgraden hier.
LTS ist ja immer schön und gut.
Aber 5.10, das ist ja von 2000.
Keine Ahnung.
20 oder so.
Machen Snapshot, ach was, YOLO.
Okay, lieb gut.
Äh ja, man muss sagen, 5G und 5 Gigahertz W-Lan hat miteinander nichts zu tun.
Das eine ist Mobilfunk, die fünfte Generation Mobilfunk und das andere ist 5 Gigahertz W-Lan.
Das ist leider aktuell etwas missverständlich für viele, was ich verstehen kann, weil halt 5 und es geht dann mit G weiter.
Aber bei dem einen sind es 5 Gigahertz und bei dem anderen ist es die fünfte Generation.
Das ist leider ein bisschen, ja, missverständlich für viele.
Deswegen finde ich es gut, dass es Wi-Fi 5 und Wi-Fi 6 heißt.
Und spätestens mit Wi-Fi 6 hat sich dem jetzt das Missverständnis dann eh erledigt.
So, wir haben rebooted. Okay, können wir mal anfangen.
Gut, das erste, was wir machen müssen, also ich habe zum Testen, wie gesagt, einen R600 hier als Access Point.
Ich mach mal ein Bild auf, weil ich mir ziemlich sicher bin, das wäre ich heute noch öfters gefragt,
haben wir hier ein schönes Hi-Res Bild davon.
Hi-Res Bild, ja, so sieht er aus. Hi-Res, Hi-Res genug, passt.
Scheiße aus, das Bild. Hi-Res. Moment.
Ordentliches, ordentliches Foto davon. Jetzt muss ich mal meine Kamera anmachen.
Large. Super Large, jawoll.
Ja, also das ist der Access Point. Eigentlich ist die interessante Seite vorne, weil der vorne die ganzen LEDs hat.
Aber hier ist er okay. Okay, jetzt lasse ich mal so auf, als wenn einer wissen, welchen Access Point wir heute testen, dann den.
Wie gesagt, verwenden werde ich den R710 nicht, den hier, aber zum Ausprobieren ist das hier eigentlich ganz gut.
So, dann brauchen wir den Country Unlock, weil ich habe ein US-Gerät gekauft.
US-Geräte sind normalerweise nicht für den Export gedacht, aber der Hersteller war so nett und hat eine Hintertür offen gelassen,
dass man die Sachen auf andere Countries anlocken bzw. ummappen kann.
Dazu müssen wir aber die Firmware downcranen. Das heißt, was wir jetzt machen werden, ist folgendes.
Als erstes müssen wir uns einen Raspberry Pi flashen, weil wir ein Gerät brauchen, von dem wir dann auf den Access Point gehen,
beziehungsweise wo wir dann auch als WLAN Gerät zum Testen ausprobieren.
Also Flash und Raspberry Pi, dann Werks oder factory, factory default den AP.
Was ich hier nicht vergessen darf, ist default user und PV, weil das ist ja mittlerweile neu.
Es gibt ja kein default user und Passwort mehr, eine der dümmsten Entscheidungen ever.
Ich weiß, wir mussten das aufgrund irgendwelcher Richtlinien machen, aber es ist richtig dumm.
Was ist mit dem Preis-Champ? Der Preis-Champ ist down.
Absichtlich down.
Genau, so factory, die Z-Access Point, dann Firmware, Firmware downgrade,
Scheiß auf Rechtsschreibfehler, Firmware downgrade, dann machen wir country, country unlock,
dann update auf neueste unleashed Firmware, neueste in Anführungszeichen, weil für den R600 die neueste Firmware von letztem Jahr.
Und dann Wi-Fi einrichten bzw. setup, Wi-Fi einrichten und dann testen mit der Raspberry Pi.
Das probieren wir heute mal aus.
So, das heißt als erstes brauche ich, nein, nicht Command-Bra, Weird-Champ.
Habe ich das gemapped auf irgendeine Taste?
Irgendwie habe ich das gerade per Shortcut ausgelöst, wusste ich gar nicht, dass ich das gemapped habe.
So, also das heißt als erstes muss ich bei Raspberry Pi flashen, das ist doch easy.
Pi imager, wo ist meine SSD?
Hier, SSD, komm mal her.
Also wir probieren das jetzt gleich mal richtig in your face aus.
Die Raspberry Pi 4s, die können mittlerweile angeblich alle ohne Umwege von SSD booten.
Das Musik ist mir viel zu laut, warum ist das so laut?
Also die Pies, die können alle von SSD booten, deswegen testen wir das jetzt mal, ob das auch alles so easy funktioniert.
Ich werde jetzt einfach das Image auf die SSD klatschen und dann den Raspberry Pi starten und dann gucken, ob alles funktioniert.
Moment, Festplatte anschließen, Festplatte anschließen.
Ist das jetzt dran? Boot, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ich will das in die, in, nee, nee.
Was davon ist meine SSD?
Moment, ich muss meine SSD in die VM kriegen.
Warum, was hat der für Schmerzen?
Was ist denn jetzt schon wieder los?
Alter, warum geht das nicht?
Monka, SHD.
Welches USB-Device ist es denn jetzt?
Welches ist es denn jetzt davon?
Ah, okay, dieses Instinct-Bombs ist es.
Okay, alles klar.
Geile Benahmung, Alter.
Das da ist es, InnoStore-USB.
InnoStore, das war nämlich vorher auch nicht da.
Okay, meine Güte.
Was war das, das immer rauszubekommen.
Ja, ja, ja, passt, alles gut.
Okay, wir können uns einfach überprüfen, ob es die richtige, ob es die richtige Karte ist.
Ob es die richtige SSD ist, kann man ganz einfach testen.
Gucken wir mal, er hat es erkannt als SDB, F-Disk, Dev-SDB.
Zwei Partitionen drauf, das Ganze ist insgesamt 1,82 Terabyte.
Das kommt ziemlich gut hin.
Und dann gucken wir noch mal, das erste ist boot und das zweite ist ein X4.
Jawoll, das ist die richtige SSD.
Sudo Pi Imager, so, Choose OS.
Leute, 32-Bit oder 64-Bit, komm, wir machen das 64-Bit Raspberry Pi drauf.
Macht im Prinzip keinen Unterschied.
Raspberry Pi OS 64-Bit Lite.
Neuer Raspberry Pi, nö, neu ist der nicht, den brauchen wir jetzt aber zum basteln.
Settings, Enable, SSH, Passwort, ja, Raspberry, ich bleib beim Default Passwort.
Configure, LAN, brauchen wir alles nicht.
Können wir insgesamt sagen, always, save, gut.
Choose Storage, 2 Terabyte.
Das passt auch, das ist eine BX500 SSD.
Right, yes.
So, während das Ding flasht, gucken wir noch mal in Chat.
Wie kann ich am besten zu Hause einen DNS Server hausten?
Ich hab Unified Gear zu Hause, will mir nicht immer die IP-Tracks von den ganzen Geräten merken.
Zwei Punkte, das sind nämlich zwei unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe,
weil bei DNS Server kannst du zwar Namen zu IPs auflösen, aber dann musst du dir Namen merken.
Und wenn du unterschiedliche Geräte hast, ist das auch nicht unbedingt immer einfach,
sich alle Namen zu merken.
Also du willst eigentlich zwei Sachen haben.
Du möchtest ein wie geahnte, wie auch immer geartete Liste haben,
wo einfach drinnen steht, was deine Geräte daheim für feste IPs haben,
beziehungsweise was die für Namen haben.
Sei es in Wiki, sei es, manche Leute nehmen auch eine Excel-Liste,
ein TXT-Dokument in Notepads, vollkommen egal.
Du möchtest als erstes eine Liste haben, wo drinnen steht,
was deine statischen IPs daheim für Geräte dahinterstecken oder für DNS Namen.
Das nächste ist, DNS Server, wenn du DNS Server hausten möchtest,
weil du dafür Anwendungszwecke hast, dann ist die beste Variante, finde ich,
weil man daheim nicht tausend Geräte haben möchte.
AdBlock Home tatsächlich, das ist zwar hauptsächlich ein DNS AdBlocker,
aber nicht AdBlock, AdGuard Home meine ich.
Aber die haben auch für den eingebauten DNS Server ziemlich viele Funktionen,
die du über das UI steuern kannst.
Das ist alle mal besser als für jemanden, der das noch nicht gemacht hat,
ein DNS Mask oder Bind MonkaS daheim selbst zu wursten.
Also ich muss sagen, das beste User Interface für ein 0815 DNS für Heimanwender
ist tatsächlich sowas wie AdGuard Home.
Windows DNS ist ja mal der Obercrap, Alter.
Du kannst natürlich auch, hast du irgendwie einen Router,
wo du statische DNS Einträge machen kannst, kannst du den genauso benutzen.
Aber wenn du einen extra DNS Server haben willst, ist das besser als Piehall.
Ich finde die Settings, die darüber hinausgehen,
neben dem AdBlock ist AdGuard Home die schönere Lösung, ja, finde ich.
Ansonsten kannst du natürlich auch jenen x-beliebigen DNS Server nehmen,
die du schon hast, sei es statische DNS Einträge in deinem Router DNS
oder wo auch immer du sonst noch DNS bei dir laufen hast, ja, kannst du auch machen.
Aber wenn du vielleicht eh schon einen AdBlock DNS zusätzlich haben wolltest
oder eben was schönes mit UI suchst, finde ich AdGuard Home eine schöne Sache,
weil du musst ja die AdBlock Sachen da drinnen nicht verwenden,
wobei ich die tatsächlich für Mobile Geräte sehr praktisch finde.
Es hat aber schönes Management UI für den DNS Mask, der unten drunter ist.
Du kannst Upstream-DNS festlegen pro Client, du kannst Sachen blocken pro Client
oder du kannst ganz einfach statische DNS Einträge machen, um gut ist.
Ist nice, finde ich.
Das ist PaintsChamp.
Ja, die C4 ist halt natürlich insofern recht,
dass es noch jede Menge andere Management-Lösungen gibt, um sowas zu machen.
Aber einen iPad habe ich tatsächlich auch nicht zu Hause.
Ich hatte mal eine Weile mit dem Gedanken gespielt, sowas wie Netbox oder so zu verwenden,
aber ganz ehrlich, für was daheim, für was?
Meine Datenbank daheim ist zu 99% mein DHCP-Server im Router,
wo ich einfach nachgucken kann.
Und mein DHCP-Server hat eh quasi so gut wie bei allen statische Einträge,
also Fixed-Einträge für Pro Mac mit Kommentarfeld.
Also ich habe im Prinzip zu 95% alles in meinem DHCP-Server drin stehen,
wenn ich was nachgucken muss.
Core DNS habe ich noch nie ausprobiert.
Das ist irgendwie so eine super krasse Cloud-Native-Geschichte.
Klingt gut.
Das ist irgendwas in Go programmiertes, würde ich mal sagen,
weil es ist...
Ist es das?
Makefile sieht nicht nach Go aus.
Doch, es ist Go.
Habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Wieso das Stream mit 48 FPS gestreamt wird ganz einfach?
Weil du mit 48 FPS die optimale Kombination hast
aus flüssigem Content und mehr Bandbreite pro Bild.
Wenn du 60 FPS hast, also stell dir vor, du streams mit 6 Mbit,
dann hast du bei 60 FPS für jedes einzelne Bild
weniger Bandbreite zur Verfügung als mit 48.
Und mit 30 FPS ruckelt das Stream mehr als mit 48.
Der Unterschied zwischen 48 FPS und 60
ist auch bei schnelleren Games für den Zuschauer
nicht so wirklich zu erkennen.
Aber die Bildqualität ist, finde ich,
gerade bei nicht so super hohen Bitraten besser.
Also ich finde, 48 FPS, ich verstehe gar nicht,
warum nicht mehr Leute mit 48 FPS streamen.
Ich finde, 48 FPS ist die optimale Kombination aus Bitrate.
Wir dürfen nicht vergessen, wir haben Internet in Deutschland,
da hat nicht jeder irgendwie 16 Mbit plus.
Leider ist die optimale Kombination aus Schärfe der Bilder
und flüssiger Bewegung.
So, jetzt schauen wir mal, ob der fertig geflasht hat.
Was zum...
Können sie mich verarschen?
Das ist abgekackt, oder?
What the fuck?
Was zum Teufel ist denn da los?
InnoStore Removable Disk.
Ja, das mache ich jetzt mit der Disk.
Auch die wird jetzt removed.
So, Disk ist removed.
Nein, die Disk ist removed.
Aha, Disk is removed, das hat er plötzlich gecheckt.
Was ist denn das?
Ist der Adapter für ein Arsch oder was?
Was ist mit der...
Ich mache mal einen anderen Adapter kurz dran.
Ja, aber selbst über USB 2 müsste das flutschen.
Warum hast du nur erstmal die paar Images an ich auf dem Haus-System?
Weil ich im Prinzip alles, was mich unter Windows abfuckt,
einfach unter Niedungsmache.
Und Kommandozeilen, Bedienung und solche Sachen flaschen,
ist was, was mich unter Windows abfuckt.
Hier habe ich noch einen anderen Adapter.
Nehmen wir mal den.
Vielleicht geht es damit besser.
Weiß nicht, was der für Schmerzen hat, ehrlich gesagt.
Also, diesen SSD auf USB Adapter, den habe ich seit Monaten schon
hier am Raspberry Pi dran und der funktioniert ohne Probleme.
So, Connect to Virtual Machine, Poggers.
Dann machen wir das Ganze nochmal.
Ich hätte eigentlich gedacht, der ist schon längst fertig flaschen, aber okay.
So, SDB, wunderbar.
Pi Imager.
Next.
Choose OS.
Am 64-Spit wird es ja nicht gelingen.
Am 64-Spit, light.
Choose Storage.
Jawoll, 2TB.
Einstellung, bla bla bla bla.
Save.
Right.
Gut.
Gebe ihm.
Das Passwort ist...
Ah, das sieht schon besser aus.
Das sieht auch schon besser aus jetzt.
Wollt grad sagen, was war das denn vorher?
Das Passwort ist 123456.
Ja, das sieht doch schon ein bisschen praktisch aus.
Keine Ahnung, was der eben für Schmerzen hatte.
Ich weiß nicht.
Alles klar.
Donut.
You can now remove.
Nee, das machen wir nicht.
Habe ich SSH eingeschaltet, Leute?
Egal, schauen wir mal kurz.
Ich glaube, ich habe SSH eingeschaltet.
Mount, Def, SDB1 nach MNT.
MNT, gibt es da ein SSH-File?
Nee, touch SSH.
Kann nichts schaden.
Sicher ist sicher.
You mount.
MNT.
Jaja, ich muss Super-User sein.
Sync.
Gut, dann machen wir das mal an den Raspberry Pi dran.
Und lassen den booten.
Und ich gucke mal nebenbei in meinem Router,
was er für eine IP bekommt.
Sekunde, Leute.
Ich muss mal kurz das Netzteil dran stöpseln.
Netzteil.
Dann brauchen wir hier das Kabel.
Netzwerkanschluss.
Und ich glaube, mir verpasst nichts Spannendes.
Und zack.
Er ist an.
Alles klar.
So, ich verbinde mich gleich auf den Raspberry Pi.
Und dann schauen wir uns das zusammen an.
Nebenbei Router aufmachen und mal DHCP gucken,
was das Ding für eine IP bekommt.
Leases.
Okay, warten wir es ab.
Hat noch keine IP gekriegt.
Ich gucke jetzt einfach mal zu, bis der gebootet hat.
Er bootet auch.
Zumindest blinkt er wie verrückt an der Netzwerkschnittstelle.
Nicht an der Netzwerkschnittstelle.
An der SSD-Aktivitätslampe.
Das ist immer gut zu sehen.
Dann funktioniert es nämlich.
Ja, Chat, warten wir mal, bis es gebootet ist.
Bootchamp.
Es hat sich gerade ein Ding, eine IP geholt,
der das Poggers heißt.
Haben wir den Raspberry Pi Poggers genannt?
Oder ist das meine VM?
Ah, das ist meine VM.
Poggers.
Da ist er.
Ich habe ihn.
SSH12202x138.
Pi add, da ist er.
Ja, Verification failed.
Piss dich, Aldo.
SSH keygen-r.
Da, bumm.
Yes, Raspberry.
So, und was ist das Erste, was man macht, Leute?
Das ist das H-Copy-ID.
Und jetzt kann man sich ohne Passwort einloggen.
So muss man das machen.
Weil ansonsten musst du jedes Mal Raspberry Pi austippen.
Wie kann ich Pi-Hole oder PF-Sense,
das sind zwei unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe,
oder PF-Sense ins Netzwerk einbinden und gewährleisten,
dass der ganze Traffic über den Pi läuft.
Du hast PF-Sense auf deinem Raspberry Pi, oder wie?
Oder wo, oder was, oder wie?
Da musst du dein Setup etwas genauer beschreiben.
Das kann ich mir jetzt gerade zu wenig reinzumachen.
So, abinstall, git, t-marks, d-stat,
was auch immer man da so alles gebrauchen konnte.
Erstmal ein Update vielleicht machen.
Warum ist denn das so lahm?
Das müsste doch eigentlich flutschen auf der SSD hier.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Das ist ja schnarchlangsam.
Ah, Moment, habe ich da einen USB-3-Anschluss?
Zack, Zack.
Ja, habe ich, ja, habe ich, habe ich.
Was ist denn mit der SSD los?
Ist die irgendwie am verrecken, oder was?
Ich meine, was ist denn mit, das ist viel zu langsam.
Das testen wir jetzt gleich mal,
ob die SSD vielleicht am verrecken ist.
So.
Erstmal so Update.
Liegt dann der Musik.
Nee, die Musik ist eigentlich dafür zuständig,
dass man sich viel besser fokussieren kann.
So, wir gucken mal,
wie schnell der wirklich auf der SSD schreiben kann.
Mein Lieblings-Mini-SSD-Benchmark.
Weil vor DD habe ich immer Schiss.
Jedes Mal, wenn ich DD eintippe,
mache ich wirklich Real Life so vorm Rechner.
Deswegen, was mir persönlich viel lieber ist,
ist die Kombination hier.
PV, Input, Def, Zero, Output, Bloop, Punkt, Image.
Nö.
Naja, aber immer noch schnell genug, oder?
Ich meine, SSD-Geschwindigkeit an USB 3
ist jetzt vielleicht nicht so krass berauschend, aber...
Okay, es sollte auf jeden Fall reichen.
So, haben wir unseren Raspberry Pi am Start.
Passt eigentlich alles.
Müssen wir sonst noch irgendwas machen.
Lass mal in unser To-Do gucken.
Raspberry Pi, Flashing, Def,
So, jetzt müssen wir in Access Point,
Factory Defaulten.
Ich nehme den Pi-Horn als Beispiel.
Wie kann ich das gewährleisten,
dass der ganze Traffic über den Pi läuft?
Brauche ich da eventuell zwei Netzwerkkarten?
Also, wie gesagt, das mit dem Pi-Horn,
das ist ja DNS.
Das hat ja an sich mit Netzwerk sonst nichts zu tun.
Also, was du machen musst,
um zu gewährleisten, dass dein gesamter Traffic
durch den Raspberry Pi läuft, ist...
Ja, zwei Netzwerkkarten ist auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt.
Du musst deinen Raspberry Pi als Gateway verwenden.
Du stöpselst deinen Raspberry Pi an den Switch,
wo alle deine anderen Rechner dranhängen,
und benutzt den als Gateway.
Und im Prinzip auf der anderen Seite
routet dann der Traffic raus zum nächsten Hopp.
Du musst deinen Raspberry Pi als Gateway verwenden.
Das hat nichts, aber auch gar nichts mit DNS zu tun.
Das ist Netzwerkeinstellung weit unterhalb von DNS.
Du musst den Raspberry Pi als dein Gateway einstellen.
Was du dann aber auch nicht hinbekommen wirst,
ist, dass Traffic innerhalb des gleichen Netzes,
also quasi...
Okay, Draw IO, Leute, Draw IO.
Draw IO.
So, Router.
Neues Bild.
So, also...
Wo ist denn schön, dass der... Router.
Das ist das offizielle Cisco-Bild für Router,
by the way, hier.
Das ist dein Raspberry Pi.
Ähm...
So, dann haben wir noch einen Switch.
Gibt kein schönes Switch-Bild.
Wie war Cisco das Bild von einem Switch noch,
wenn man das Bild von einem Raspberry Pi
von einem Cisco-Bild von einem Switch noch mal...
So, so.
Ne?
Das ist das Cisco-Switch-Bild.
Switch.
Ich möchte das...
Please.
Wie kann ich das denn resizen,
ohne dass die...
Na, wurscht.
Also, das hier ist der Router.
Und das hier ist, sagen wir mal,
ein 24-Port-Switch.
So, und hier hast du deine PCs dran.
Kann PiHol auch Netzwerk-Firewall?
Ne. Dafür ist es nicht gedacht.
So, und hier hast du deinen Desktop.
Deine Desktop-PCs dran.
So.
Plop.
Und hier geht's dann weiter zu deinem Provider.
So.
Diese Heizung da ist dein Provider-Mode.
Was jetzt passiert ist,
dein Raspberry Pi muss das routen.
Das hier ist der Default-Gateway.
Den hier musst du als Default-Gateway angeben.
Also, quasi von dem internen Interface.
Also, das interne Interface
hat dann beispielsweise
70.1
oder so.
Das ist das interne Interface und das hier
ist dann dein externes Interface. Das kann was auch immer.
Ist burscht. Irgendwas zu deinem
Modem.
Keine Ahnung.
10.1.1.1.
1.
Das ist aber egal.
So, so würde das Ganze
dann aussehen. Und die Dinger hier brauchen
als Gateway diese IP.
Das wird dir aber auch noch nicht
alles bringen, weil...
So. Gateway.
Ups.
So. Das müssen die
als Gateway verwenden. Die Rechner
hier unten.
Und dann werden sie alles,
was nicht im gleichen Netz ist,
an den
an den Router schicken und er schickt das
weiter. Was du damit
nicht erreicht ist, wenn
dieser Rechner
zu diesem Rechner
kommunizieren will.
Weil
das ist im gleichen Netz.
Das geht nicht
über den Router.
Also gehen wir mal davon aus,
der hier hat irgendwie keine Ahnung.
70.
70.200
oder so.
Als IP.
Und der hat
70.201
als IP.
Dann passiert Folgendes. Wenn der Rechner
wenn der hier
mit dem Rechner reden will,
dann macht der hier einen Uprequest
ins Netzwerk. Quasi einen Broadcast.
Wo er fragt, sag mal
was ist denn die MAC-Adresse?
Passend zu
192.168.70.
Punkt
eins. Und
also das ist, wenn man TCP da macht,
sagt man immer Who has?
So und dann antwortet der hier drauf
mit seiner MAC-Adresse.
Und dann kann der hier das direkt an den
adressieren. Das heißt es geht in diesem
Switch-Port rein.
Und in diesem Switch-Port raus.
Sofern der Switch diesen Rechner schon einmal gesehen hat.
Ansonsten geht es erstmal an alle raus.
Weil der Switch ja selbst noch lernen muss,
welche MAC-Adresse, welche MAC-Adresse
sind hinter welchen Ports sind.
Also direkte Kommunikation
zwischen
diesen beiden
Rechnern
bekommst du so
ohne weiteres nie
über einen Zwischen-
Hopp. Ja?
Weil es gibt keinen Hopp in dem Sinn.
Und da kann man jetzt auch so einfach nichts dran
ändern. Das ist so wie das Netzwerk
technisch halt
funktioniert.
Wie kann man denn die Dicke hier machen?
Also da kannst du nichts dran
ändern. Aber sobald du
deinen Router als Gateway verwendest,
dann wird alles was aus diesem
Netz raus will woanders hin
zwangsläufig über den Router
geschickt. Und dieser Router kann dein Raspberry Pi
sein oder irgendwas anderes.
So ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr
wer das gefragt hat, aber
ja.
Kann man auch machen wobei es
selbst da nicht unbedingt was bringt.
Weil
WLAN-technisch ist das
das hier, das ist
zwar kein WLAN mit WLAN-Tags,
aber im Prinzip macht ein WLAN was ähnliches.
Nur dass du quasi mit einem WLAN
diesen Switch nochmal in zwei logische Switches
wenn du es so willst unterteilen könntest.
Und natürlich kannst du
Trunk-Ports machen zwischen zwei verschiedenen
Switches. Also
das würde an der Sache nichts ändern.
Also das Rechnern die im gleichen WLAN
sind und im gleichen Netz
kommunizieren können miteinander
ohne dass sie über den Router gehen müssen.
Also an der Kommunikation
dass diese Kommunikation dir nicht über den Router geht
kannst du eigentlich nichts ändern.
So ist das
von der Technik her halt nun mal nicht
gedacht. Du musst
nicht über den Zwischenhub gehen solange du im gleichen Netz
bist.
Ja wir können tatsächlich etwas weniger
Einschläfe in der Musik machen, das stimmt schon.
Nein.
Wo waren wir denn?
Hatten wir auch schon oft.
Bio-Card.
Okay.
So.
Mir geht es nur darum,
dass alle Clients nur über Pyholl
ins Internet gelangen. Also
ob da jetzt Pyholl die richtige
Wahl für ist das als Router hinzustellen
sei mal in Frage
gestellt oder sei mal dahin gestellt.
Aber
das könntest du
so regeln.
Möchtest du vielleicht sicherstellen
nicht dass die wirklich da drüber gehen
sondern dass alle deinen DNS
Server verwenden? Ist das vielleicht
eher das was du willst? Willst du das
alle Pyholl als DNS verwenden?
Dann musst du nämlich einfach nur in deinem DHCP
Server einstellen, dass das
als DNS verwendet werden soll.
Also wenn du einfach nur willst, dass alle
Leute bei dir im Netz Pyholl
als DNS verwenden.
Dann musst du an deinem
DHCP Server einstellen DNS Server
die IP vom Pyholl. Fertig. Mehr net.
Dann können die Clients zwar immer noch
verwenden was sie
wollen als DNS Server.
Aber standardmäßig verwenden
sie Pyholl.
Ja genau. Alternativ kannst du nämlich einfach
alles andere blocken. Auf Port 53
oder TCP 53 ja mittlerweile
auch.
Oder das Pyholl als DNS verwenden.
Kannst du DHCP verwenden.
Das kannst du auch machen.
Aber so sieht es aus.
Siehste deswegen ist immer wichtig, dass man genauer
erklärt was denn die Leute eigentlich wollen.
Weil das manchmal gar nicht so
das ist was man auf den ersten Blick versteht.
So also wir sind auf unserem Raspberry Pi.
Das haben wir hingekriegt.
Und jetzt sind wir wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Access Point resetten.
Factory Default Access Point.
Können wir downcreate und country
unlocken.
Alles klar.
Ok. Also.
Dann geht's gut.
Dann widmen wir uns mal unserem Access Point.
Nämlich dem Teil hier.
Also wir müssen jetzt resetten.
Wo habe ich mein Access Point?
Ja den Access Point
resetten man übrigens da ist hinten.
Am Access Point
ist ein.
Irgendwo
ist ein Knopf zum resetten.
Das seht ihr jetzt nicht. Das mache ich jetzt einfach.
Und gut ist.
Und dann leuchtet er rot nachdem er resettet wurde.
Und
ja dann resettet er sich halt.
Was soll ich da noch groß zu sagen?
0W
Reset. Stopp 12 Sekunden
oder so. 1 2
3 4 5
6 7
8 9 10
11 12 13
14 15
So. Access Point
resetten sich. Exzellent. Geschafft.
So.
Dann checken wir das doch
jetzt mal.
Und zwar es sollten sich jetzt
eigentlich zum konfigurieren
ein extra
WLAN öffnen. Das checke ich mal auf meinem Handy
und dann connecten wir uns mit dem Raspberry Pi
zu diesem extra WLAN.
Und ich brauche jetzt Unleashed
Setup Wizard.
Diesen Guide dafür. Nicht Witcher.
Setup your Unleashed Wifi.
So. Setup
Process Unpack
WTF
Das müssen wir jetzt
machen. Genau.
So. Ich sollte jetzt
ein WLAN hier haben.
Das sich nennt Configure Me.
Hab ich aber nicht.
Weil der noch nicht fertig gebootet ist vermute ich mal.
Nee habe ich noch nicht.
Wieso machst du das nicht
über SSH?
Es gibt noch nichts worauf man sich per SSH verbinden kann.
So. Configure Me.
Configure Me. Gut.
Also. Dann gehen wir jetzt mal zum Raspberry Pi
und sagen Raspberry Config.
Und wir verbinden uns
zum Access Point.
System Options
Wireless
Uh.
Moment.
Wo stellt man das nochmal ein?
Hallo?
Germany?
Ok. SSID. Also.
Configure
Punkt Me
Minus
3 7
Hab ich das jetzt richtig geschrieben? Ich hoffe mal.
Passphrase gibt es nicht?
Finish.
Leak.
Reboot.
Warum soll ich Rebooten?
Na gut. Meinetwegen Reboot. Ok.
Warum muss der Rebooten um das WLAN zu aktivieren?
Ach der muss Rebooten weil er die
Länderkennung irgendwie ändern muss
vom WLAN glaube ich.
Ich hab keine IP.
Das Ding hat seinen Config WLAN
offen. Ich hab das gerade resettet.
Vielleicht wird es eine IP
bekommen. Wenn ich es an
DHCP internt. Aber wir machen das mal nach
ihrer Anleitung. Also.
Ich hab mich jetzt zu diesem Configure Me
wieder anverbunden. So da sind wir wieder.
Schauen wir mal ob das jetzt funktioniert.
If Config.
Guck mal da.
10 52
was zum
Das scheint mein
Gateway zu sein.
Ok. Also wie gehts
weiter? Wir verbinden uns
zu Configure Me und dann
Depending on your
Browser. You may be presented with a security
warning bla bla bla bla.
Ach ne. Ach Moment. Ich muss das
mit einem Browser machen. Ok. Zeit für SSH
Forwarding.
Abinstall
Chrome.
Browser.
Das mag ich ja an Raspberry Pi.
Alter.
Ja komm gib ihm.
Das
die nicht Snaps ausliefern
sondern noch richtig echte Packages.
Also wer denkt NPM
install installiert viel. Der muss
erstmal ein Chrome installieren.
Gut. Mit dem Unterschied
das bei JavaScript
ein Hello World schon mehr
Downloads braucht als das da.
Chromium kommt
mit Pearl Chrome. Ja keine Ahnung. Wahrscheinlich.
Genau.
Das ist wegen X. Hast recht.
Pearl wahrscheinlich wegen X.
X 12
minus eins.
Ok.
SSH
minus C minus Y.
PassWD. Ich vergebe jetzt ein super krass
geheimes Passwort.
Ok. Perfekt.
Bestes Passwort. Das wollte ich schon immer mal.
Ach so. Current Passwort. Lul.
So. Beste.
Ok. Und jetzt starten wir
Chromium Browser.
Und dann schauen wir mal ob das hier funktioniert. Was die da
schreiben. Wir sollen
also wir sind connected
Sekunde. Ich mach nochmal kurz aus.
Mein T-Max auf. Also
wir sind connected mit
dem Access Point
Configure WLAN
und jetzt sollen wir angeblich da
auf diese IP gehen.
Unleashed löst
das Ding überhaupt auf. Da bin ich jetzt mal sehr gespannt.
Rougus
Wireless.com
Nö. Natürlich nicht.
Ok. Jetzt war mal Trick 17
Leute. Massive.
Massive Trick. Gucken ob das
tut.
Wir sind verbunden mit dem Access Point
und der Access Point hat
diese IP.
Geh ich mal ganz stark von aus. Weil
die hier hab ich und das ist die andere die es
gibt. Das ist der Access Point.
Und
Was machen wir jetzt?
Hosts Eintrag.
Genau. Das, das
Was?
Kein Wim installiert. Cringe
wer keinen Wim installiert hat. Alter.
Richtig
Cringe
ETC Hosts
Ehm
Rougus
Was da?
Allerdings Sekunde
Auf diese IP.
Bin mal gespannt ob das jetzt klappt was ich mir da überlegt hab.
Du du du du du
Du du du
Ok. Chrome Browser
Emacs.
Ja. Ganz bestimmt ist der Lichtbild da ein Emacs für.
So. Gucken wir mal ob es jetzt funktioniert.
Und Post Jam. Post Jam. Hey
Your Connection is not private
Oh mein Gott
Mein Connection is not private
Fuck
Ok. Also
Unleashed Installation
Nein wir wollen ein lokales Upgrade machen
From a Local Image
Weil ich muss
Downcrateen damit ich die
Country Unlock machen kann. Ok
R600
Leute ich ziehe den Access Point nochmal ab
Ich hab keinen Bock dass die ganze Zeit hier so lange
ein offenes WLAN am Start ist
R600
Download. Firmware Download
Unleashed. Oh no
Also wir brauchen nämlich eine Firmware
Und jetzt kommt der Knackpunkt. Also
Ich hab einen Access Point gekauft
Der
Ähm
Für die USA gemacht ist
Damit man den in Deutschland betreiben darf
Muss man ihn auf
Deutsch umstellen. Weil wir unterschiedliche
Reglementierungen haben was
Sendeleistung angeht. Channels
Frequenzen was auch immer
Standardmäßig geht das nicht
Wenn du es versuchst standardmäßig zu
Ändern. Dann bekommt man als
Antwort
Illegal to change Country Code
Deswegen gibt es einen Trick
Wie man den Access Point umstellen kann
Oder besser gesagt wie man den
Im Prinzip gibt es für Access Points plus zwei Regionen
USA oder nicht USA
Nicht USA kann alle anderen Länder
auswählen. USA kann nur USA
So. Und
Mein Access Point ist leider
Etwas älter, den ich hier hab
Der ist pre 2020
Weil wie gesagt heute testen wir es ja mit dem
Alten. Und
Deswegen muss ich
einen Firmware Downgrade
Durchführen. Damit ich
Mir eine Root Shell besorgen kann
Über eine Sicherheitslücke auf dem Access Point
Und wenn ich die Root Shell habe
Auf dem Access Point dann kann ich mein
Country Unlock machen
Und danach kann ich auch Upgraden
Auf eine Firmware die die Sicherheitslücke nicht mehr hat
Also richtige Hacker Mans
Hacker Mans Zeug heute
Soweit verstanden Chet
Ist das soweit klar
Also ich muss jetzt erstmal die Firmware downgraden
Auf einen Release vor November 2019
So
Hier
Unleashed vor
Ich brauch einen Unleashed
Moment was was schreiben die
Vor
November 2019
Unleashed 2020
In welcher Farbe der Access Point ist
Hier so cremefarben weiß
So Unleashed vor 2019
2018 2019
Vor November 2019
Hat er gesagt
Also das hier ist wahrscheinlich die Firmware mit der sie das
gefixt haben die Sicherheitslücke
Das heißt wir brauchen eine
Firmware die
Älter ist also die
Da zum Beispiel
File Name, Download
Okay, oh
Komm on, please
No god
No
Seriously zum Download von einer Firmware muss ich mich registrieren
Na gut
10 minute mail
Ja genau
So wollte ich schon immer mal heißen
Ich habe, Kein account. Ja ja
First name keck last name we email
Passwort
Ja genau das nehme ich jetzt auch gerade dass ich dann jeder damit einloggen kann hier null
So ja ja wir excepten alles sec I
Register
Ja save mal wer weiß ob ich sie noch brauche
Thank you darf ich denn downloaden vielleicht jetzt schon
Darf ich darf ich vielleicht so schon downloaden ohne dass es vielleicht erlaubt
Ja ja genau login
Okay
Warten dass ich firmen runterladen kann bis ich eine bestätigung email bekommen habe das doch lächerlich alle
Ne das muss so funktionieren ich brauche kein link
Ah
Aha
Thank you in order to complete process click den link below
Um no
blade
Aja okay alles klar
Die
Link vielleicht noch jetzt. Seid mal so nett.
Hey, meine Session, meine Session gilt noch.
Leute, ihr könnt jetzt alle meine krasse Session hijacken hiermit.
So. Also. Zum Download ist Curl besser.
Okay, da haben wir es.
MV, wir benennen das mal kurz um.
In das da, weil ansonsten erkennt das wahrscheinlich am Ende nicht mehr.
Okay, wunderbar.
Also Browser, Browser, Down Cran.
Rokos.
Ah ne, haha, nicht nicht downcran.
Ich muss den Access Point erst wieder einschalten.
So. Wo ist hier meine Anleitung dazu, wie das funktioniert?
Alles klar.
Ping. Noch ist er nicht da.
Hoffentlich behält er auch seine IP.
Und randomize die nicht oder so.
Ach so, ja, was ist denn jetzt eigentlich hier?
Bin ich noch im? Ah, guck mal, mein WLAN hat sich disconnected.
Aber der Raspberry Pi sollte erkennen, wenn das WLAN wieder oben ist
und sich wieder neu connect champion.
Irgendwann. Ich gucke mal auf mein Handy, ob das Teil wieder da ist.
Nope.
Nope. Ah ja, jetzt ist er wieder da.
Raspberry Pi, Connect, please. Connect, please, Connect, please.
Muss ich jetzt rebooten, dass der sich wieder connectet?
Nee, oder?
Der sollte sich auch alleine wieder.
Connecten.
Das ist ein R600, das ist hier zum für den Stream zum ausprobieren.
Okay, anscheinend nicht. Benutzen werde ich dann ein R710.
Konfigure.
Minus 3, 7, D, C, 4, 0.
Finish.
Raspberry Pi, please.
Kann man dem irgendwie sagen, reconnecten?
Wie kann ich dem sagen, reconnecten?
Das ist doch nicht euer Ernst, dass ich rebooten muss jetzt, oder?
Meine Güte.
Die Dinge reconnecten sich doch immer automatisch.
Ich meine, ich habe Raspberry Pi im Keller stehen, im Erdgeschoss stehen, am 3D-Drucker
und selbst wenn ich meine Access Points gebe, die Dinge reconnecten sich immer automatisch.
Ach, kein Plan.
Wir rebooten einfach. Reboot geht immer.
Reboot-Champ.
If-Config.
Hallo, please.
Connecten.
Aha.
A minus N.
Der hat auch die gleiche IP.
Okay, wir können weitermachen.
Chrome.
Okay.
Also wir downcreate'n jetzt.
Wir downcreate'n jetzt die Firmware.
Das heißt, wir gehen jetzt dahin.
Zack.
Wir gehen auf die Adresse.
Irgendwelche konnten nicht mal funktionieren.
Was ist denn jetzt schon wieder?
Hat er doch gecheckt?
Er hat's doch kapiert, dass es die Adresse nicht gibt.
HTTPS.
Ja, Browser, was ist das Problem?
Browser.
Hallo.
Okay.
Okay, was auch immer.
Hä?
Moment.
Ist die IP falsch?
Schauen wir mal.
Also das ist die IP.
Hosts.
So, richtig.
So.
Den CD ist auch ein Firefox zusätzlich, wenn Chrome dich will.
Ja, es heißt Firefox ESR.
Nein, das ist das einfachste von der Welt.
Wenn du fucking Browser auf eine IP, äh, auf eine, auf eine, auf eine Uhre gehen.
Das muss doch funktionieren.
Auf Firefox, mach hin.
So, dann machen wir Firmware downcreate.
Wenn wir Firmware downcreate gemacht haben, loggen wir uns dort per SSH ein.
Und...
Jo.
Das war's.
Dann probieren wir das aus.
Okay, ping, ping tut er.
Das ist doch schon mal ganz gut.
Firefox.
Was?
Ach so, ich bin root.
Null.
Daran liegt das.
Ja, logisch.
Firefox.
Nee, die haben keine komische Lizenz.
Nur wenn du denen ihren Controller verwenden willst.
Oh komm, Firefox, please keine Animation.
Das ist x-forwarding über SSH.
Kann ich Animation jetzt wirklich nicht gebrauchen?
Geh mal weg.
Flexgrill.
Ich brauch keine Animation jetzt.
Komm, Firefox, please.
Ich mach gleich ein Socksproxy und mach das mit meinem Browser lokal.
Okay.
Mach das mit meinem Browser lokal.
Was ist denn das hier?
Okay.
Schließt.
Ich kann das Fenster nicht mal beenden.
Bam.
So, da geht es jetzt vielleicht mit dem Chrome.
Jetzt funktioniert es.
Okay.
Was auch immer.
Komm, geh doch mal auf.
Jetzt ist doch alles gut.
Gut.
Excellent.
Okay.
Firmware Upgrade bzw.
Firmware Downgrade.
Upgrade ist ein Licht-RP vom local-image.
Next.
Ähm.
Ja.
Äh.
Nein.
Es gibt wenig Sinn, was da steht, aber okay.
So, Firmware Upgrade bzw.
Downgrade.
Okay.
Warum kein Unify?
Äh, warum kein Unify?
Weil mir Features fehlen.
Und ich auch allgemein nicht glücklich bin mit meinen Unify-Dingern.
Das ist jetzt nur zu...
Also, ich hab mir zwei gekauft.
Ich hab mir einen R600 gekauft.
Und zum rumspielen und ausprobieren.
Weil ich noch nie was mit diesen Exist-Points gemacht habe.
Und mit einem R710, das ist quasi das Vorgängermodell vom aktuellen.
Kostet aber auch nur ein Achtel auf Ebay.
Äh, dann zum benutzen hier.
So.
Firmware Downgrade.
Local Upgrading will take few minutes.
Yes.
Server Java Pages.
Ah ja, das ist der Firmware von sonst wann.
Ist mir egal, was das benutzt.
Hauptsache es funktioniert.
Now Upgrading.
Er Upgraded.
Was macht der?
Er blinkt komisch.
Ähm, der ist überhaupt nicht erreichbar, der Exist-Point gerade, oder?
Nö.
Schauen wir mal.
Doch, er ist noch erreichbar.
Alles gut.
Jetzt hat er rebooted.
Guck mal, jetzt hat er rebooted.
Jetzt ist er nicht mehr erreichbar.
Was hast du für den R710 gezahlt?
Äh, 260, 70 Euro in dem Dreh.
270 Euro.
Ziemlich, ziemlich, ich weiß es nicht auf Cent genau, aber ziemlich, ziemlich genau 270 Euro.
Wir können ja mal kurz neben bei Just For Fun gucken, was es auf Ebay gerade so kostet.
Rogus.
Schauen wir mal, was zuletzt eingestellt wurde.
Äh, beste Ergebnisse neu eingestellt.
Also 500 würde ich nicht kaufen, ist quasi zu alt, auch End of Life und gibt keine Firmware mehr.
Entweder R610 oder R710 oder meinetwegen auch R510, aber noch irgendwas, was halbwegs aktuelle Firmware bekommt.
Besser natürlich sogar.
Ja, sowas könnte man sich zum Beispiel holen, aber wie gesagt, ganz schön teuer.
Ähm, so.
Aber, Chet, nachdem, ganz bestimmt, aber nachdem ihr ja gesehen habt, dass der Country Unlock funktioniert, gucken wir doch mal hier.
Weil bei den Amis, die Dinger sind billig.
Ist er, bei den Amis kriegst du die teilweise schon, na okay.
Alter, letzte Woche hatten wir noch was für 240 Dollar, ist teurer geworden.
Ich will das Unifile Zeug loswerden.
Ja, also bei den Amis hast du wahrscheinlich noch ganz gute Chancen, was zu bekommen.
Hull.
Alter, diese Preise, man.
So, hat er jetzt upgraded?
Hat er es jetzt geschafft, endlich?
Nee, der pingt immer noch wie verrückt.
Okay.
So, er ist aber angeblich wieder oben.
Aber pingen tut er nicht.
Er pingt wahrscheinlich nicht, weil sich mein Raspberry Pi wieder disconnected.
Warum disconnected sich mein Raspberry Pi?
Der kostet 1,4K, ja, das ist aber ein bescheuerter Preis.
Selbst der aktuelle kostet weniger.
Was?
Sag mal.
Man muss das Ding doch force reconnecten können, über Kommandozeile.
Aha, das da habe ich gesucht.
Das habe ich gesucht.
So, da hat sich nicht reconnectet, WLAN technisch.
Das heißt, schauen wir mal.
So, den Browser machen wir mal zu, können wir gleich wieder öffnen.
Da steht es aber, man soll ihn nicht schließen, aber ich meine, who cares, was da steht.
So, reconfigure.
Du darfst dich jetzt please neu connecten.
Raspberry Pi, es ist erlaubt, dass du dich neu connectest.
Der access point steht 10 cm von dir weg.
Sag nicht, dass du den nicht sehen kannst.
Oder er ist mit dem Upgrade noch nicht fertig.
Aber keine Ahnung, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Was sagen denn meine LEDs?
Meine LEDs sagen, dass Power und Dear blinkt.
Heißt das, der update jetzt noch oder?
Kannst du das WLAN, ja, ich sehe das WLAN noch am Handy.
Ich kann mal gucken, ob ich mich connecten kann.
Ach, wobei, scheiß drauf, das wird schon gleich funktionieren.
Wisst ihr was, ich reboote jetzt null.
Schade auch nichts.
Connecten wir uns mal.
Connect Champ auf.
Der hat keinen Bock, sich zu connecten.
Der denkt sich Nope.
Wait a minute.
Das da ist aber nicht die richtige IP.
Das ist diese IP, die WLANs bekommen, wenn sie keine IP bekommen.
Das ist diese Autokonfig-Geschichte.
IW-Konfig.
SSID, Konfigami ist doch gut so.
Alter, das macht mich fertig.
Warum kann er sich nicht einfach verbinden?
Ich gucke mal, ob ich da mit dem Handy draufkomme.
Ja, mit dem Handy komme ich da.
Mit dem Handy komme ich drauf.
Und ich kriege auch eine richtige IP.
Oh, keine Ahnung.
Warum ist das, warum sind einfache Sachen teilweise so schwer?
Was soll das?
Ok.
Raspi-Konfig.
IW-Konfig.
Ich mach das jetzt einfach nochmal.
System, Wireless.
Jawoll.
Yes.
Finish.
Pause-Camp.
Alter, Raspberry Pi, was ist denn jetzt dein Problem, Mann?
Was ist hier, warum geht das nicht?
Ich kann mich doch mit meinem Handy auch connecten.
Von welcher Marke, das ist der hier.
So, jetzt im Stream gerade ist es der hier.
Verwenden werde ich deinen R710.
Jetzt sag mal, will mich das Ding verappeln?
Also der Access Point muss mittlerweile fertig sein mit dem Upgrade.
Der Access Point muss mittlerweile fertig sein mit dem Upgrade.
Ich ziehe jetzt den Access Point gleich raus.
Und Reboote den nochmal.
Ich meine, das Update läuft jetzt schon drei Minuten oder so oder zehn Minuten oder lange.
Warum eigentlich F-Konfig nicht IW-Konfig, weil ich wissen will, ob ich eine IP bekommen habe oder nicht.
Ja, du hast das richtig gegoogelt, aber deswegen kauft man die sich auch gebraucht auf Ebay.
Also, ich habe keine Ahnung, was er verschmerzen hat hier.
So, ich Reboote jetzt mal beides.
Ich Reboote den Access Point.
Und dann kann ich jetzt den Access Point verabschieden.
Ich hoffe, ich habe jetzt nicht gebrickt, weil ich ihn während dem Update ausgeschaltet habe.
Und ich Reboote den Raspberry Pi auch, sobald das WLAN da ist.
Was ist denn an dem Ding so krass?
Gut, das hier ist ja die vorvorletzte Generation, die würde ich mir jetzt nicht unbedingt noch kaufen.
Wie gesagt, aber ich werde dann den R710 verwenden, weil er richtig coole Features hat,
wie zum Beispiel, dass du jedem Gerät ein extra Passwort geben kannst.
Auch Geräten, die keinen WPA Enterprise unterstützen.
Was gerade für IoT-Geräte so ein richtig hyper-nices Feature ist.
Ein POG-Feature.
Access Point, starte dich neu.
Ok, Configami ist da.
Raspberry Pi Reboot, wenn es jetzt nicht geht, dann rast dich aus.
Ich will nicht, dass es lädt, weil wenn es lädt, dann stürzt es ab oder so.
Das ist eigentlich das, was am einfachsten gehen sollte.
Sich einfach mit dem Raspberry Pi auf Next-Point verbinden, so schwer kann es doch nicht sein.
Der connectet sich nicht, warum?
Warum connectest du dich nicht, Raspberry Pi, was soll das?
Die Anzeige ist zehnfach raus schon.
Warum connectest du dich nicht?
Zu nah dran, Quatsch, das hat doch vorhin auch funktioniert.
Wenn es lädt, kannst du es nicht flashen, das ist richtig.
Ok, wo ist das?
Ich lösche jetzt die Wi-Fi-Config.
Ok, Raspberry-Config.
System, Wireless LAN.
Configami, heißt das Ding wenigstens noch so?
Moment, Kontrolle.
Configami, 37DC40.
Kein Passwort, Finish.
Nein, das ist nicht prickt.
Ich sehe es mit dem Handy und kann mich mit dem Handy connecten.
Aber warum connectet sich mein Raspberry Pi nicht, was ist das?
Ja, die SSID ist noch die gleiche.
Was zum Teufel ist das für eine Kacke?
Nochmal Reboot.
Leute, ich kann doch nicht laufen Rebooten das Ding, Reconfig.
Ok, ok.
Configure.me minus 37DC40.
Genauso.
Warum connectet sich der Kram nicht?
Was ist das?
Ich checke es nicht.
Ich kann es jetzt mit dem Handy machen, aber ich will, dass ihr das seht.
Der Country-Code ist falsch.
Warum sollte der auf einmal falsch sein?
Der war eben doch noch richtig.
Tja.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Warum sollte das jetzt nicht mehr klappen?
Tja, Leute, jetzt bin ich gerade sehr planlos.
Was machen wir denn jetzt?
Ich resette den Access-Point noch mal.
Wir haben jetzt das Firma-Downgrade gemacht, da kann ich ja resetten.
Und dann sollte es wieder funktionieren.
3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16.
So, Access-Point resettet sich.
Das Gerät schon 50 Mal neu gestartet.
Reboot.
Also, das ist auch echt beknackt, Alter.
Nein, das will ich nicht.
Ich will kein IW-List machen.
So, das Ding resettet sich jetzt, rebootet, blinkt wie verrückt.
Sollte gleich wieder oben sein.
Ich sehe es ja dann am Handy, wenn es da ist.
So.
Noch ist es nicht oben.
Gut.
Also, Raspberry-Config.
Ich tippe das jetzt gleich noch mal vom Handy ab.
Da ist es.
Also.
Perfect.
Ure.
Konfigure.
Punkt.
Mi.
Minus.
Drei.
Sieben.
DC.
Vier.
Null.
Bam.
Was hat das Ding?
Aber wo kann ich mich WLAN-mäßig nicht mehr connecten?
Was ist das denn?
Du hast vorhin keine Updates beim Pi gemacht.
Ist doch vollkommen egal.
Der Access-Point ist auf.
Ich sehe das Ding in meinem Handy.
Und ich konnte mich vorhin direkt mit den exakt gleichen Settings dahin verbinden, dahin
verbinden.
Warum geht das jetzt nicht mehr?
Was ist das denn?
Kann doch nicht sein.
Nee, der Access-Point ist nicht kaputt.
Ich sehe es auf dem Handy und kann mich auf dem Handy dahin verbinden.
Aber mein Raspberry Pi hat keinen Bock da drauf.
Was absolut keinen Sinn ergibt.
Warum sollte der sich ja zwar immer nicht mehr hin verbinden können?
Lull.
Nee.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Alias Felby willst du machen.
Alias.
Tja Leute.
Ich habe ernsthaft keinen Plastenschimmer.
Warum das nicht funktioniert?
Der muss sich doch jetzt verbinden zum Access-Point.
Warum macht der das denn nicht?
Und ich klicke das Setup nicht mit dem Handy durch.
Ah ja, da hast du recht.
Da könnte man tatsächlich mal reingucken.
Gibt es nicht.
Lull W.
Muss man bestimmt was einschalten, oder?
Syslog?
Nö.
Es kann doch eigentlich nichts sein.
Ich meine, es hat sich doch, außer dem Firmware Downgrade auf dem Access-Point hat sich doch
nichts getan.
Mein PC hat WLAN.
Mein Handy sagt, dass es da ist.
Es ist alles da, Mann.
Messages?
EPA.
Block.
Wie kriegt man den Kramper her?
Äh.
Minus D?
Was?
Wie?
Wo?
Was?
Ich weiß nicht, was ihr von mir wollt.
Wie kriege ich von meinem Netzwerk Interface?
Minus W ist doch vollkommen egal.
Ich hab doch da gerade schon reingeguckt.
Minus W ist nur warten, bis neues Zeug reinkommt.
How to enable logging?
Ja, genau.
It's complicated.
Das ist ja schon mal toll.
Was ist das?
Alter!
Warum ist da nach dem Firmware Downgrade nicht mehr in der Lage, sich im WLAN zu verbinden?
Ich bin geneigt, das einfach auf dem Handy durchzuklicken jetzt und drauf zu scheißen,
aber das kann doch nicht sein.
Der muss sich doch verbinden.
Es ging doch vorhin alles.
Das kann nicht sein, dass sich da irgendwie großartig was geändert hat.
So, also der Name ist auch komplett richtig.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie ich das dem beibringen soll, dass der sich da jetzt verbindet.
Es regt mich schon wieder auf, dass so einfache Dinge wie Connecten zu einem WLAN nicht funktionieren.
Tja.
Irgendwas buggy am 64-Bit.
Vielleicht.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Passt zum.
Das ist ja mal eine Feifert-Ausgabe.
Das hab ich sogar noch nie gesehen.
Was sagt denn der eigentlich?
Der sagt gar nichts.
Ja, super.
Geil, das wird uns nicht allzu viel bringen.
Also Logs gibt es ja aus irgendwelchen Gründen da nicht dazu.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie man das dem beibringen soll noch.
Ich mein.
Mehr als sagen, verbinde dich mal im WLAN.
Du kannst ja nicht machen.
Ja, das können wir gucken, aber da wird doch auch nicht mehr stehen.
Ja, geil, nice.
Das, was man auch bei Status gesehen hat.
Pock oder or not Pock.
Nö, der hat gar keinen Bock.
Den interessiert das absolut gar nicht.
Leute.
Es ist doch scheißegal.
Das ging doch eben bis vor das Firmware Update Mann.
Denkt doch mal nach, bevor ihr irgendwie ultra krasses Backstreet und alles den gleichen Blödsinn schreibt.
Das Einzige, was ich gemacht, das ist im Firmware Downgrade vom Access Point.
Da wird bestimmt nicht auf einmal von 2,4 Gigahertz auf 17,5 Gigahertz funken oder so jetzt auf einmal.
Es ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn, wenn schon.
Also das wahrscheinlichste, was ich mir irgendwie erklären könnte ist,
also wirklich irgendwas mit dem 64-Bit Raspberry Pi OS zu tun hat.
Weil ansonsten ergibt es überhaupt keinen Sinn, warum er sich nicht zum Access Point connecten sollte.
Zumal, wenn ich mein Handy nehme und klicke das WLAN an,
dann geht er ins WLAN und freut sich seines Lebens und sagt, ja gut, kriege IP, alles gut.
Also das WLAN ist offen, daran liegt das nicht.
Das liegt einzig, weil der Raspberry Pi da aus irgendwelchen Gründen keinen Bock hat,
sich in das WLAN zu verbinden.
Der Name ist richtig, das Passwort ist richtig.
Aber er hat keinen Bock.
Und ich weiß nicht, warum.
Wir könnten das vom Rechner aus machen.
Ja, das könnten wir machen.
Jetzt geht's.
Nee, der kriegt keine IP.
Aber ihr seht, dass es prinzipiell funktioniert, aber er zieht sich keine IP.
Warum nicht?
Okay, scheiß drauf, wir machen das jetzt anders.
Wir machen das, wir machen das anders.
10.
Ich hab das nämlich kein Bock, so ewig.
10, 2, 3, 1, 1, 5, 1.
So.
Nee, eins verschieben.
1, 2, 5.
So, das geht natürlich nicht.
Jetzt, hat funktioniert.
Easy.
Einfach 50 Maribou und es funktioniert.
Alles klar, gut.
Also, könnt ihr alles in eurem Kram schon mal vergessen, ihr hattet alle nicht recht.
Ich auch nicht.
Aber man muss einfach nur oft genug rebooten, dann funktioniert's.
So, easy.
Dazu kann man nur sagen.
Easy as fuck.
Easy as get rekt.
Okay, jetzt funktioniert's.
Teamwork's Chrome.
Okay, und jetzt gehen wir auf.
Unleashed.
Da gehen wir jetzt hin.
Und wenn er jetzt wieder nicht funktioniert mit seiner komischen Seile, dreh ich, dreh ich ab.
Jaja, es ist auch HTTPS.
Nein, Gott!
WLAN as a service, ja.
AP ist richtig.
Okay, das mit dem reconfigure ist Blödsinn von Stack Overflow, das funktioniert nicht.
Die Musik passt gut, ja, finde ich auch.
I reconnect WiFi CLI.
Nein, if up, if down ist bescheuert, da gibt's was.
Ja, das funktioniert bei mir aber nicht.
Kann man vielleicht einfach sagen.
Nope, kann man nicht.
Vielleicht ist wirklich ein Problem vom 64-Bit.
Ich bin geneigt auf 32-Bits zu downcranen.
So, einmal reboot ich den Kram noch, dann wird er neu geflasht.
Hab da kein Neff drauf.
Brauchst du lieber ifconfig?
Ganz ehrlich, ich hab mich schon jahrelang an ifconfig gewöhnt, aber ich versuche immer, wenn ich mich bei im ifconfig tippen erwische, eigentlich IP-Ed zu machen.
Aber ganz ehrlich, eigentlich ist es wurscht.
Eigentlich ist es egal.
Heutzutage ist es eher IP vorinstalliert als ifconfig.
Aber naja.
WLAN ist down.
Aha, sehr schön.
Gut zu wissen.
WLAN ist down.
Warum?
Weil WLAN down ist.
IPA?
Ja, ich benutze immer IP-ID.
WLAN ist down.
Okay, WLAN ist down.
Weil man weiß, dass ja WLAN ist down.
Das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
WLAN ist down.
Easy, WLAN down.
WLAN ist einfach down.
Einfach down.
Mal gucken, ob der gleich noch startet.
WLAN ist down.
Das ist ihm egal.
WLAN macht bad kill.
Ja, hat keinen Bock.
Einfach down.
So, pass mal auf.
Wir sagen ihm jetzt einfach, sich nochmal zu connecten.
Da.
Bam.
Nö, wollen wir nicht.
Haben wir keinen Bock.
Vielleicht mit 433 Mhz-Versuche.
Über LoRa funken am besten.
Oh, guck mal.
WLAN ist jetzt ab, oder?
Ups.
Finish.
Nein.
WLAN ist nicht ab.
Okay, Leute.
Ich flash den Raspberry Pi jetzt.
Ist mir egal.
Ich flash den jetzt mit 32.
Ist mir zu blöd.
Access point aus.
So.
Kann nicht sein.
Das einfachste von der Welt funktioniert wieder nicht.
Was ist hier los?
Triple Anzeige, Alter.
So.
Wo habe ich meinen?
Flaschen.
Flaschen 32 Spit.
Ist mir egal.
Bam.
Imager.
Zack.
Choose OS.
OSA.
Light 32 Spit.
True Storage.
2 Terabyte.
Blah.
Ja, ja.
Alles gut hier.
Pi.
Yes.
Arch Arm.
Da kann ich auch Arch, by the way, haben auf meinem Raspberry Pi.
Das ist gut.
Kann ich der Welt mitteilen, dass ich Arch verwende, auch wenn es um Raspberry Pies geht?
Das finde ich.
Das sollten wir unbedingt mal machen.
By the way.
Einzig wahre Betriebssystem.
Yes.
Continue.
Sudo.
Minus I.
Ich bin mal.
Ich habe immer noch geguckt.
Mount.
Also was hat das denn gemountet?
STB.
Mount.
MNT.
Touch.
SSH.
Zack.
UMount.
SYNC.
So.
Ab.
Bulldum.
Ran an den Raspberry Pi.
So.
Da.
USB.
Stecker.
Switch.
Blob.
Einstöpseln.
Gut.
IP sollte gleich bleiben.
Weil.
Ich habe vorhin Static Reservierung im DACP gemacht.
Ich lasse den nextes Point noch aus.
Bis der Raspberry Pi hochgefahren ist und alles funktioniert.
Ich dreh durch, Alter.
Warum ist so einfacher Krempel immer so brutalst schwer?
Nächste Mal nehme ich mir einen WLAN USB Stick und schleif den durch an meine VM und mache
das von der VM.
Ich mein, wer konnte davon ausgehen, dass es mit dem Raspberry Pi ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit
ist, sich in den WLAN zu verbinden?
Hätte man jetzt nicht mit gerechnet eigentlich, oder?
Chat sagt auch in der letzten Zeit das Gefühl, dass die einfachsten Sachen immer broken
sind.
Ja, echt so.
True.
LohnW.
HDX.
Auf Raspberry Pi.
Gib ihm.
Also die SSD Aktivitätsleuchte ist wie verrückt am Plinken.
Eingestöpselt ist er auch.
Angeblich habe ich da Wim auf.
Was?
Achso.
Meine Tutu.
Ah, da ist er wieder.
SSH.
Bam.
Ach ja.
Minus.
Minus R.
Erst mal löschen.
Jetzt.
Yes.
Raspberry.
Jawoll.
SSH.
Copy ID.
Sehr schön.
Yes.
Ja.
FASWD.
Raspberry.
So, Dominosie.
Update.
Ich meine, jetzt haben wir 32bit, wenn es jetzt nicht, ich mache den Access Point schon mal
wieder an.
Wenn es jetzt nicht funktioniert, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Upinstall T-Max Chromium Großer.
Hau mal alles.
Wir optimisern das jetzt.
Ich muss eh rebooten für die WLAN Settings, für die Länder WLAN Settings und dann mache
ich jetzt gerade noch ein Kernel Update schnell auf dem Ding und dann sollte der Access Point
nach oben sein.
Ja ja, ich mache auch noch ein Upgrade.
Auf, gib ihm.
Volle Pulle.
Sag mal, ist mein Raspberry Pi am verrecken gerade?
Ich meine das ernst.
Ihr habt doch eben gesehen, eben ging das doch dreimal so schnell.
Was hat er jetzt auf einmal für Probleme?
Das ist doch definitiv nicht normal.
Ist halt nur 32, ja, aber das hat doch keine Geschwindigkeitsunterschiede in diesem Ausmaß.
Gut, ich meine, wir können das ja mal parallel machen.
Was ist das da oben schon wieder?
RGB, ja stimmt, daran könnte es liegen.
Vielleicht sollte ich noch RGB einschalten.
Ok, tragen wir den Krempel schon mal ein.
Ok, also System, Wireless, Germany, ah nee, yes, config-ure.me-37dc, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
dc-40, keiner ist das ID.
Reboot!
Scheiße drauf, cake wait, yes!
Rebooten wir einfach während des Updates, wird schon gut werden.
Wird schon alles funktionieren.
Noch ist er angeblich hier, jetzt ist er nicht mehr da.
Doch, er ist immer noch da.
Warum ist er immer noch da?
Aber Connection Refused
Kann das sein dass der irgendwie rumspackt weil ich ihn Rebooted hab während er Updates gemacht hat
Ne der hat ein ganz gutes Case, der wird nicht Throttlen, der wird irgendwelche anderen Probleme haben
Gut Leute
Geht nicht anders Strom raus Strom rein und dann hoffen dass noch alles funktioniert
Geht der Boot noch? Okay er leuchtet, grün ist schon mal gut, grüne Lampe geht aus und blinkt jetzt gleich hoffentlich
Ja ja sieht gut aus, er sollte Booten, er sollte Booten, ich muss ja noch ein Updates machen, vielleicht verbinde das jetzt aber auch WLAN technisch
Okay auf Raspberry Pi
Praige Chat, Praige, Praige, Praige
Praige mal ne Runde
Wir brauchen jetzt sehr viel Praige dass es funktioniert
Also Booten tut er, er sollte eigentlich wieder da sein
Ich hoffe ich hab jetzt nicht irgendwie geschrottet weil ich im laufenden Betrieb einfach den abgezwungen hab
Gut der bootet nicht oder
Alter was ist denn heute los man?
Ich will mich einfach nur zu einem Axis Point verbinden und einen Webbrowser aufmachen
Das kann doch nicht sein, dass so die einfachsten Dinger nicht funktionieren heute
Ich mach da gleich ne Micro SD Karte rein und dann ist Ru wenn er mit SSD so rumspackt
Ich flash schon mal ne Micro SD Karte, ich hab jetzt echt keinen Nerv drauf
So ich mach den Axis Point nochmal aus
Ich flash jetzt ne Micro SD Karte, 32G Micro SD Karte, fertig
Gar kein Bock mehr auf den Scheiß jetzt
So ich mach den Axis Point nochmal aus
Ich flash jetzt ne Micro SD Karte, 32G Micro SD Karte, fertig
Gar kein Bock mehr auf den Scheiß jetzt
Normalerweise sollte das mit SSD deutlich zuverlässiger sein, aber gut wenn er nicht will
Wenn er nicht will, dann kriegt er halt
Nein, du sollst nicht dahin, du sollst, nein geh sofort
Yes
Der ist wirklich ja verreckt jetzt
Cack wait alter was ist das
So Pi Imager
Choose OS, wir nehmen wieder 32Bit
32Bit Lite
Storage 32G SSD
Was
Would you like to apply
Image customization settings
Image customization settings saved earlier
Ja ist doch gut
Ok lass mich gerade an der Raspberry Pi nicht mehr gebootet bin in der Zwischenzeit
Weihnachts Noobsinks zurück
Nein
Ok SSD
Pass mal auf
Weißt du was wir mit der SSD jetzt machen
Pass mal auf, mit der SSD machen wir jetzt den Scheiß
Mit der Crap
Kackdinger
Das kann doch nicht sein, dass das beim Note, dass das sich einfach
Ja ich hab gerade die SSD gegen die Wand geschmissen, aber
Es sollte ja wahrscheinlich nichts passiert sein
Läuft
Jetzt Micro SD rein
Fertig
Micro SSD
Das ist gar keine Micro SSD, so ein Schwachsinn
Gibt es, Moment
Micro SSD
Auf die Idee ist noch keiner gekommen
Ich hab noch nie eine SSD gegen die Wand geschmissen
Aber die hat es echt verdient
Weiß nicht was das für ein Crap ist
Vielleicht liegt er auch am Raspberry Pi
Ich weiß nicht, keine Ahnung
Ok, jaja, continue
Ist gut
So, sudo minus i
So, mount
Mount
MNT
SSH
Nee, touch SSH
Ok, gut
Unmount
MNT
So, jetzt mach ich die Micro SD Karte rein
Jetzt hoffentlich
Alter, funktioniert's jetzt
Dreh durch
Dauert sowas immer so lang
Ganz einfacher Kram, mann
So, wo ist denn jetzt das Netzteil
Da
So, er ist an
Ping
Warten bis er oben ist
Oh
Eine Bohrmaschine ist super
Nein, ich will sie ja nicht kaputt machen
Die SSD ist auch bestimmt nicht kaputt gegangen
Vom gegen die Wand schmeißen
SSDs sind äußerst robust
Robuster, deutlich robuster als Festplatten
Also Magnetfestplatte wäre jetzt hinüber
Hätte ich die gegen die Wand geschmissen
Welche Nexus Point gibt es denn heute
Im Stream zum testen
Gibt es den hier
Gekauft habe ich mir den und einen R710
Den R710 werde ich verwenden
Und den habe ich jetzt hier zum testen
Und ich dachte nicht, dass wir
Zwei Stunden Leute, wir sind schon über zwei Stunden
Zugange und haben noch nicht mal den Kram geflasht
Weil der Raspberry Pi keinen Bock
Hat heute
Wie sieht es denn aus
Die SSD
Leuchtet durchgängig
Das ist meistens kein gutes Zeichen
Wenn die SSD durchgängig leuchtet Leute
Durchgängiges
Leuchten von SSDs heißt meistens
Dass irgendwas mit dem Read nicht funktioniert
Sag mal, ist der Raspberry Pi wirklich
Im Arsch
Da ist doch wirklich irgendwas
Kaputt
Jetzt blinkt er
Vielleicht hat das Resizing einfach nur eine Weile gedauert
Ne, ich werfe aktuell, garantiert kein Raspberry Pi
An die Wand, weißt du wie teuer aktuell
Und wie schwer zu bekommen Raspberry Pi 4s sind
Ne, ne, das den schmeiße ich nicht, da schmeißt lieber die SSD
Gegen die Wand
Die SSD war nie schuld
Das weiß man nicht
Er bootet noch, er blinkt
Leuchtet jetzt durchgängig
Alter was ist denn jetzt das Problem
Auf, starten
Also die IP muss die gleiche sein
Die IP muss die gleiche sein gleich
Der bootet nicht
So ganz im Ernst
Ah
Leute, das ist doch nicht normal
Dass es so lange braucht
Selbst beim ersten Boot nicht
Wie heißt die Library
Wo du für den Label Drucker gebraucht hast
Für die Labels zu machen
Library
Gar nichts, das haben wir selbst gemacht
Oder meinst du Kubs
Ah, erstmal Update machen
Ah, die kennen uns leider wie Conva
Conva hieß das
Conva, Conva GS
Es ist nicht Fabrik, es ist Conva
Hier, Conva GS
Das haben wir verwendet
Das müssen wir auch noch fertig machen
Übrigens
Upgrade
Ich komme ja zu nichts
Und wenn einfache Dinge schon so ewig dauern
Es käme Wunder, dass das nichts wird
Nein
Wie kann das sein, dass wir über 2 Stunden brauchen
Um uns auf den Exitpoint zu verbinden
Das ist eine Sache von 2 Minuten
Normalerweise
Ok, ähm
Chrome muss ich noch installieren
Up, install, Chrome
Chrome
Chromium, Rosa
Yes, hau drauf, hau drauf, gib ihm
Gib ihm, volle, volle Kerne
Volle Pulle
So, danach Rebooten
Exitpoint anmachen
Und dann Prege, Leute
Dass es funktioniert
Wenn es funktioniert
Dann erzähle ich euch meine Theorie woran es gelegen hat
Und ihr könnt mir sagen
Ob ihr es für wahrscheinlich haltet
Oder nicht
Aber nur wenn es funktioniert
Weil wenn es nicht funktioniert muss ich euch meine Theorie auch nicht erzählen
Nico, danke für den Sub
Wir können ein bisschen Chat gucken wo wir gerade dabei sind
Warum habe ich eigentlich Pe-Po-Po-Po nur eingeblendet
Musik
Wie gesagt, ich will das Zeug damit ersetzen
Hier, da ist OMG, ist der Programm hier bei dem Shop
Oder? Bei 1400 Euro Exitpoint Preisen
Entweder 64 Bit ist RIP oder SSD
Nein, ich vermute was anderes oder auch
Aber erzähle ich euch dann wenn es funktioniert
Wie gesagt, mein Handy sagt ja es funktioniert
Meine Antenne stört
Ja, das ist es, das wird es sein
Haha
Das wird es sein
Mach es kurz davor
Engel German Kit, genau
Unreal Tournament
Betke macht der Raspberry Pi
Der Raspberry Pi
Deswegen nehme ich normalerweise eine SSD
Weil es damit 3 mal schneller geht
Als mit der Micro SD Karte
So, wir schalten schon mal den Exitpoint ein
Dass der ready ist sobald ich
Musik
Chat, jetzt wo so viele da sind
Ich frage euch mal was
Ich habe aktuell eine ganz billige Fritzbox
Für Deckt und Voip
Das Unity Media
Kabelmodem als Einwahlgerät
Und ein Mikrotik Router für Routing
So weit so gut
Und ihr wisst ja, ich habe ziemliche Probleme
Mit dem Fernsehempfang drüben
Weil mein Raspberry Pi mit USB Stick
rumspackt
Deswegen habe ich einmal zur Auswahl
Entweder mir so ein Ding zu kaufen
Allerdings, wie gesagt, nur als Empfänger
Im Wohnzimmer bleibt weiterhin
Mein Shield TV dran
Das würde ich nur benutzen
Als Empfänger
Das hat 8 Tuner drinne
Ein Oktatuner sozusagen
Und das würde ich benutzen zum Streamen
An das Kodi auf dem Shield TV
Also, was haltet ihr für sinnvoller
So ein Ding zu kaufen
Oder ich könnte mir auch eine Fritzbox
Kabel kaufen
So was da
Ich könnte mir auch eine Kabel Fritzbox kaufen
Die hat einen Quad Tuner drinne
Und ich könnte damit quasi
Das Unity Media Modem
Und
Meine
Meine Billig Fritzbox ersetzen
Und hätte noch gleich einen Tuner dabei
Was meint ihr
Ersinniger, preislich nimmt sich
Lustigerweise gar nicht so viel
Der VU Plus
Ganz ehrlich, ich tendiere auch zum VU Plus
Weil das Ding wohl echt
Nice, also
Qualitativ echt nice sein muss
Was die Tuner angeht
Aber wie gesagt, ich möchte die VU Plus
Nicht benutzen als Endgerät
Am Fernsehen, nur als Empfänger
Und Streamer
Also, mein Shield TV mit Kodi
Bleibt weiterhin im Wohnzimmer
Und ich werde dann einfach dort
Das Kodi Plugin
Verwenden dafür und darüber streamen
Aber ich meine, die VU Plus hat einen Vorteil
Es ist ein weiteres Gerät
Ich bin ja mittlerweile kein Fan mehr
Von so Single Point of Failures
Weil
Dazu kommt
Leute, ich bin dumm
Das geht überhaupt nicht
Ich brauche eine Fritzbox und einen Raspberry Pi
Mit TV Headend
Weil ich will doch aufnehmen
Und die Fritzbox aufnehmen mit TV Headend geht ja gar nicht
Also ich bräuchte quasi die Kombi
Fritzbox plus Raspberry Pi mit TV Headend
Und SSD dran
Oder quasi eine Box für alles
Mit SSD drinne
Also, ist denn jetzt
Ok, configure me
Respy config
System wireless LAN
Deutschland
Konfigure, Punkt
Ich kann es fast auswendig
Minus 3,7 DC 4,0
Yes
Keine Passphrase
Yes, yes, Reboot
Vorgass
Gut
So, und wenn es jetzt geht
Sag ich euch woran es gelegen hat
Ich hab nämlich eine Vermutung
Woran es gelegen hat
Und dann müsst ihr sagen
Max, das ergibt Sinn oder nicht
Oder ihr seid Weirdchamp
Ich hab letztens
Alles auf die Fritzbox umgestellt
Von so einer Enigma Box
Oder von wo hast du auf die Fritzbox umgestellt
Und mich würde interessieren, wenn du von so einer Box umgestellt hast
Warum?
Weil wie gesagt
Fritzbox umstellen alleine bringt ja nichts
Man braucht ja noch
Raspberry Pi mit TV Headend zum Aufnehmen
Und das muss problemlos
Funktionieren der ganze Krempel
Weil das ist für meine Mutter
Also der Kram da muss laufen
Ich hab keinen Bock
Dass ich Support geben muss
Okay
Hydroleon
Ich hab keine Ahnung
So Leute
Wir sind verbunden
Das hat funktioniert
Nein, Cody kann nicht mit der Fritzbox aufnehmen
Du kannst mit der Fritzbox
Du kannst mit Cody ein IPTV Addon verwenden
Das kann aber nicht aufnehmen
Gescheit
So, es funktioniert mit dem WLAN
Alles klar
Arp minus N
So
Etc, Hosts
Abinstall
Woran hat es gelegen
Sag ich euch gleich, sobald ich im Browser drauf bin
Ich sag euch woran es gelegen hat
Dann werdet ihr sagen Max FyFat
Er gibt keinen Sinn
Okay, auf
Wim etc
Hosts
Zack, und jetzt wo muss ich drauf
Unleashed.com
Egal ob der da irgendwelche
Alza Packages entfindet
Geh einfach auf
Das war gerade die Windows
Tastatur
Bogus
Jawoll
Da sind wir Leute, wir haben es geschafft
Okay, ich sag euch woran es gelegen hat
Also, ich vermute
Das lag an der SSD
Allerdings nicht weil die SSD kaputt ist
Sondern ich vermute das liegt daran, weil die
SSD zu viel Strom gezogen hat
Ich vermute die SSD hat zu viel
Strom verbraucht
Und deswegen hat das WLAN rumgespackt
Weil der Raspberry Pi, der ist
Nicht so üppig bemessen
Was
Stromverbrauch am USB Anschluss
Geht und manche SSDs brauchen halt ordentlich
Was, ich glaube der Raspberry Pi kann
Maximal 0,5
Also 500mAh am USB
Oder 1A mittlerweile am USB
Und SSDs
SSDs brauchen halt manchmal ein bisschen
Mehr, wenn man
Ich meine, ich hab die SSD da schon lang dranne, keine Ahnung
Aber ich hab nie WLAN in Kombination damit
Verwendet und wahrscheinlich
Braucht das Ding zu wenig
Zieht das Ding zu viel Strom, dass es halt auch instabil
Wird, was die SSD angeht
Ihr habt ja gesehen, wie die Performance-Dinger von der SSD
Gespankt ist. Okay Leute, wir sind hier am Start
Also, wir müssen
Es jetzt einrichten
Also, Language, Englisch
Name, Rogus Unleashed
Country Code
Ähm, by the way
Ihr seht, dass ich hier den Country Code auswählen kann
Das liegt daran, weil ich das
Mit dem Country Unlocked, das habe ich euch
Schon gesagt, schon gemacht habe
Aber, wie gesagt
Wir machen es trotzdem nochmal zusammen, dass ihr seht
Wie es funktioniert
Ja, es ist die alte Version drauf
Ich stelle aber Country Code schonmal auf da
Name ist Qt
Chat
Language, Englisch
Kein Mesh, Germany, jawoll
IP-Settings
DHCP ist ok
Kann er behalten
Kann ich mich von dort an
Darauf verbinden
Vom Raspberry Pi
Wenn ich das dem dann
Primary DNS, alles vom DHCP ziehen
Na, ich flashe da nichts auf 64
Spitt jetzt
Gut, next
Wireless LAN, SSID
Passwort-Produkt, ja
Das WLAN heißt Vodafone
Tarnung ist alles, keck weh
Moment
Ah, ich hab mich vertippt bei meinem WLAN-Passwort
Moment, Moment, Moment
Ah, ich kann mein WLAN-Passwort nicht
Richtig tippen gerade, the fuck
Englisches Tastatur-Leon, Monka
Alter, was ist denn das
Was zum
Ja, so will ich das haben
Geht doch
Ok, das nehmen wir als WLAN-Passwort
Also, WLAN-Passwort
Gutes Passwort
Next
Administrator-Passwort
Ja, huge massive Passwort
Kommt nie einer drauf
Next
Alles klar, finish
Unleash will restart
After you click, ok
Nein, nein, ich klicke, yes, nicht ok
Yes
So, jetzt muss ich
An meinen Router anstöpseln
Gleich, next point und dann in
Dann in
In meinen Router schauen
Was der für eine IP bekommt
IP
DHCP Server
Elises
Rep, rep, rep, rep, rep, rep, rep, rep, rep, rep
Elises Musik
So, sollte sich das Ding jetzt neu gestartet haben
Mal schauen
Elises Musik
Ich glaube, Leute, es hat sich neu gestartet, oder?
Sollte passen
Elises Musik
Mal mal das hier dicht
Aus ist
Elises Musik
Ok, also
Der Raspberry Pi
Elises Musik
Mal gucken, ob das jetzt auch aus ist
Der access point
Elises Musik
Ja, ist aus
Ok, das heißt
Der access point sollte jetzt, wenn ich den anstöpseln
An meinen Switch
Dann sollte der sich eigentlich
Jetzt eine interne IP holen
Und ich kann mich drauf verbinden
Elises Musik
Soweit die Idee Strom raus
Anschließen
Elises Musik
Und rein
Und jetzt gucken wir mal
Elises Musik
Schauen wir mal, was passiert
So
Elises Musik
Auf booten, please
Boot plitz
Elises Musik
Sollte irgendeine 192.168.2
120 oder so
Bekommen wahrscheinlich
Elises Musik
Jetzt hat sich gerade ein Rechner mit dem Namen Six
Hätte eine neue IP gezogen
Meine Hausnamen werden auch nicht gerade kreativer
Elises Musik
So, Porgas hat sich auch wieder eine neue IP gezogen
192.168.2
Elises Musik
Moment, mal ausprobieren
Vielleicht
Elises Musik
Elise Musik
Ich hab
2.140 hab ich hier zur Auswahl
Elises Musik
Das andere ist mein Desktop
Also Ping
ialeinstanz
2.140
Okey nmap
Mal gucken was da läuft
Das similar guet aus
könnte durchaus ein Axis Point sein oder auch nicht. 100 für ein, ne. Das ist er glaube
ich. Das müsste der Axis Point sein. Warum auch immer es nicht aufgeht im Browser aber
das ist glaube ich der Axis Point. SSH. Was? Alter wie alt ist denn das SSH da drauf?
Achja HTTPS ihr habt recht aber eigentlich solltet ihr auch redirecten oder? Ne macht
er automatisch. Ich gehe davon aus dass der das ist. Abyss ist offen. Alles klar. Moment
da ist überhaupt nichts offen auf Port 80. Da ist er das doch nicht. Okay wir können
ganz einfach testen ob er das ist Leute. Wir pingen den und ich ziehe jetzt den Stecker
raus. Wobei anhand der Mech sollte ich es doch eigentlich auch erkennen. 2.140. Mechatris
was ist das? Mech. Ruckus jawoll. Das muss er wohl sein oder? Ah jetzt der braucht einfach
nur 3 Stunden zum booten Alter. Guckt euch das mal an. Alles klar. Nein nicht wirklich
Firefox nicht wirklich. Gut versucht aber nein. Admin 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 wahrscheinlich
wenn ich mich so kenne. Yo. Wi-Fi Networks da sind wir doch. Nein. Skip. Ich register
nix. Wi-Fi Networks. Wodafone. Disabled. Ich will kein Network anhaben. So und jetzt
müssen wir uns eine Root Shell besorgen um Country Code zu anlocken. Also SSH. Boah
minus O Key. Was ich dann aus dem Kopf wie man das angibt. SSH Option Key Types oder
irgendwie sowas. Nein nein nein. Da brauch ich irgendwie SSH Option. Das Ding ist so
alt das unterstützt die neuesten SSH Keys gar nicht mehr. Hier. Host Key Algorithm ist
es. Host Key Algorithm. SSH RSA. POG funktioniert. Minus R. Löschen. 140. So. Yes. Admin. Da
sind wir. CLI Interface. Prager hat geholfen. So und jetzt müssen wir den Country Unlock
machen. Nämlich das da. Also deswegen haben wir nämlich downcrated by the way. Also wir
haben die Firmware downcrated, dass die Firmware noch eine Sicherheitslücke hat, dass ich
eine Root Shell bekomme. Also Enable. Debug. You have all rights in this mode. Script. Exeg.
Dass sowas, also dass sie sowas übersehen ist ja eigentlich schon fragwürdig oder?
Kann man nach dem Change wieder upgraden? Yup. Exeg. Das da. Exit. So. Und jetzt haben
wir Rootrechte. Wir haben Rootrechte. Wir haben komplett Rootrechte und und Kommandozeilenzugang.
Geht sowas da. Kommandozeilenzugang auf unseren Access Point. POG Champ. So. Knecht Root Recht.
Das ist gut. Das hab ich doch nicht gehört. Und was soll das bringen? Jetzt kann man den
Country Code umstellen von US auf weltweit. Remove Country Lock. Jetzt muss man nämlich
sagen BSP Set Fix Country Code 0. Und dann muss man sagen BSP Commit. Und jetzt hat man
den Country Code unlockt und ich kann von US auf Germany umstellen. Und jetzt Reboot.
POG. Jetzt haben wir Country Unlocked. Jetzt darf ich den nämlich auch in Deutschland betreiben.
Was ich offiziell eigentlich hätte vorher nicht machen dürfen. Braucht ganz schön
lang zum Rebooten. Und ich bräuchte kurz was zu trinken heute.
So ich bin abeck.
So gut. Also der sollte jetzt Rebooten und dann machen wir ein Firmware Upgrade. Das
können wir übrigens schon mal. Ah guck mal da ist er wieder. Der braucht eh eine halbe
Stunde bis er hochgefahren ist. Jetzt können wir uns schon mal die neueste Firmware runterladen.
Nämlich Dada. Dada. Die da. Was hat irgendjemand einen Plan was uns das heißen soll? MRGA.
MR ist so was wie Major Release oder sowas. Und GA. Ich hab keine Ahnung. GA Refresh 2.
GA3 Refresh 4. MR Refresh 6. Was General Availability. Und was ist dann MR? Major Release. Hä und
was ist der Unterschied zwischen meiner Release? Ja was denn jetzt? Chat ihr schreibt einfach
wieder irgendwas. Ihr wisst es überhaupt nicht. Der schreibt einfach irgendwas hingeschrieben
an. Magic Resistance. Ja das bestimmt. Ppega Chat Alter. Merch Request. Stell so. Danke
für den Sub. 27 Monate. Okay wir laden das aber schon mal runter. Das scheint ja das
aktuellste zu sein. Was es gibt. Okay mein Download funktioniert noch. Moment den Download
muss ich auf den. Ah ne den kann ich jetzt ja von hier machen. Nice. So sind wir wieder
am Start. Wir sind wieder da. SSH. Admin. Was? Okay was auch immer. Okay also ist alles
wieder da. Funktioniert. Exit. Oder Quit. Ja ich hab Exit gesagt und schreibe Quit und
das funktioniert ja lustigerweise auch obwohl ich nicht Exit. Passt auf immer. Gut also.
Dann können wir jetzt ja wieder Upgraden. Damit übrigens wenn wir Upgraden damit schließen
wir uns auch die Rootshell. Ach Moment. GA ist quasi ein Major Release und was ist dann
MR? Meiner Release wahrscheinlich. Das ist ja die beknacktest Bezeichnung die ich je
gehört hab dafür. So wenn wir Upgraden auf die neueste Firmware dann haben wir keine
Rootshell mehr auf dem Access Point. Weil das ein Bug war der gefixt wurde. Aber ganz
davon abgesehen es gibt Schlimmeres. Ich brauch nicht unbedingt eine Rootshell auf dem Access
Point solange der das Management und so alles in Ordnung ist. Okay Country Code. Germany
sehr schön. Also Administration. Upgrade. Checking for Updates. Wie kann er jetzt online
etwa Upgraden? Alter ich muss die Firmware nicht mehr hochladen. Guckt euch das mal an.
Weil kann direkt über Swap Interfaces Upgraden. Das ist auch das Richtige. 127. 127 jawoll.
Upgrade. Pog. Gib ihm. Master Procrest. Ja ja mach. Warning. Die Zukunft ist hier.
Und das ist von 2020 der Access Point. Also die neuen sind wahrscheinlich noch besser.
Nee 2019 ist der glaube ich. Nee noch älter. Wenn es Releases von 2018 gab. Was passiert
eigentlich wenn man in Deutschland US WLAN nutzt? Wird die Polizei bei einem Anklopfen?
Wahrscheinlich wird hier gar nichts passieren. Weil es keiner richtig merkt. Aber ganz streng
genommen ist es nicht korrekt, weil die unterschiedliche Reglement haben. Was Sendeleistung angeht,
die erlaubt sind und sowas. Wahrscheinlich wird es keiner merken. Es ist ja nicht so als
wird so großartig was stören und das deswegen auffällt und dann irgendjemand nachmisst oder
was auch immer. Wahrscheinlich wird überhaupt nichts passieren. Aber man muss es ja nicht
machen, weil das hat ja durchaus seinen Sinn. Dass es diese Vorgaben gibt. Wenn jeder quasi
mit auf der Frequenz und mit der Leistung funken, weil die lustig ist, funkt irgendwann
gar keiner mehr. Nee, nee das mit den Ländercodes das funktioniert. Das war schon deutsch und
ausgewählt jetzt. Das macht gar keine Polizei. Das macht irgendeine. Das macht irgendeine
andere Prüfstelle würde das machen und dann eventuell die Polizei rufen, wenn sie zu
dir in die Wohnung wollen. Aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass es eine Hausdurchsuchung
gibt wegen falscher WLAN-Frequenz in Deutschland. Aber trotzdem, wie gesagt, das hat ja seinen
Sinn, dass es solche Vorgaben gibt. In dem Fall ist es tatsächlich zum besseren von
allen. Weil, wie gesagt, wenn jeder funkt, wie er will, funkt bald gar keiner mehr. Okay,
er ist anscheinend wieder da. Einfach mal refreshen. Okay, neu gestartet ist er noch
nicht. Nmap. Aha, die Webinterfacesports sind noch nicht oben.
Webinterface, starte dich. Sehe ich das richtig? Da ist Telnet offen. Ach nee, Moment. FDP?
Warum genau hat der Port 21 auf? Warum ist... Wo kommt man da raus, wenn man da drauf geht?
FDP? Warum ist da ein FDP drauf?
Ja, da gucken wir jetzt auch gleich mal. Admin? References? Nee. System? Kann man das hier
vielleicht gar nicht einschalten? Services? FDP? Hm, wo könnte man sowas wie einen FDP-Sorber
einstellen? Administration? Network Connectivity? Network Management? It's a trap? Mobile App?
Kann man das ausschalten? FDP-Settings? System? System-Settings? Nö. SMS? E-Mail? Kann
man das ausschalten? FDP darf man anscheinend nicht ausschalten, okay. Nice. Management-Interface.
Reddit? Unleashed? Disable FDP? Warum ist da ein FDP-Sorber auf? Welchen Telnet-Client
hast du verwendet? Das Standard Telnet, was unter Linux dabei ist? Oder das Telnet, was
Telnet heißt, habe ich verwendet. Okay, ist jetzt auch nicht so wild. Aber, immerhin,
es funktioniert schon mal. Also, wo sind wir jetzt stehen geblieben? Update auf den neuesten
Stand? Setup? Wi-Fi einrichten? Das haben wir im Prinzip schon gemacht. Willen wir Raspberry
Pi testen? Okay, dann testen wir doch jetzt mal eines der Features, warum ich diese Dinger
nice finde. Services? Authentification-Services? Access-Control vielleicht? Alter, was kannst
du da alles einstellen, Mann? Device access? Client isolation whitelist? Application recognition
und control? Was zum Teufel? Das will ich alles gar nicht machen. Bonjour-Gateway? Ist
Bonjour nicht irgendein Apple-Ding? Dynamic PSK, ja, das ist das, was ich gleich ausprobieren
will. Guest access service? Hot-Spot? Self-Healing? Na, da bin ich ja immer sehr skeptisch. Wips?
Gut, das auch immer. Keine Ahnung. Gucken wir uns mal an die WLAN-Settings an. Also,
Vodafone-WLAN. Das ist das krasseste G-Bate-Name von einem WLAN überhaupt jetzt, oder, dass
das einfach Vodafone heißt und mit Vodafone nichts zu tun hat. So, Settings für das WLAN.
Edit. Passwort? Nein, das Passwort will ich euch nicht schauen. Advanced Settings. Genau,
hier kann man PSK einstellen. So, external, da kann man irgendeinen Radio-Server hinterlegen,
was ich nicht vorhabe. Internal. Zero-IT will ich nicht haben. Zero-IT ist bei denen sowas,
es gibt ein offenes WLAN, da kannst du dich anmelden und dort kriegst du dann quasi, also
das mit neuer Mitarbeiter meldet sich an, dort lockst du dich dann einmalig ein und dort
kriegst du dann die Zertifikate für das eigentliche WLAN. Das brauch ich nicht. Also, Dynamic
PSK will ich haben. Damit kann man von der Idee her für jedes Endgerät ein eigenes
WLAN-Passwort generieren. Das probieren wir mit dem Raspberry Pi gleich aus. Wegen sowas
gerade beim Raspberry Pi sind, machen wir SSH, gehen wir da nochmal drauf. Pi add. Sudo-i,
nicht Sido, Sudo-i. Ehm, etc, wpa, wpa. Ich lösche die WLAN-Settings mal und Reboote,
weil, ja, der Pi. Das WLAN gibt es ja nicht mehr. Ok, Key-Länge. Ganz ehrlich, auf 62
Sachen habe ich wirklich keinen Bock. Nehmen wir mal, nehmen wir mal, keine Ahnung, 20
oder so. Oder, ok, 24. 24 sollte noch reichen als WLAN-Passwort. Oder komm, wir sehen Informatik-Kurs,
32. So, expire. Ok, das ist, wenn man irgendeinem Typ ein Passwort gibt, was weiß ich, man
hat Besuch. Man hat Besuch und möchte, dass der eine, dass der das bekommt. Ok, na, das
ist ja schwachsinnig. Das brauche ich nicht. Mein Raspberry Pi soll unlimited Zugang haben.
Limit, one per device. Ja, klingt doch sinnvoll. Eins pro Gerät sollte doch reichen. Das hier
ist, glaube ich, nur sinnvoll in Kombination mit Zero-IT, dass man sich beispielsweise ein
User für seine drei Smartphones keyscannerieren kann, aber das wollen wir ja gar nicht. Ok,
WLAN Priority, Hi, Hide SSID, MonkaS, Access WLAN. Ich meine, das könnte man jetzt einstellen.
Ich habe da kein WLAN-Support gerade da in dem Switch irgendwie eingeschaltet, aber warum
nicht? Ok, was kann man sonst noch machen? Access Control. What? Ah, man kann sagen, wie
viel Bandbreite jeder Kleinmaximal verwenden darf. Das ist ganz praktisch, wenn viel los
ist. Enable per SSID, Uplink, Downlink. Das kann man auch per SSID machen. Ok, also sprich,
wenn man irgendeine Kamera WLAN hat oder irgendwie sowas, dann kann man... Das ist nice. Access
Control. Ja, wir wollen es jetzt mal nicht übertreiben. Mac Access, Layer 3 und 4 Access,
policies. Das will ich alles gar nicht machen. Radio Control. Was ist 802.11RFT Roaming? 802.11RFT
Roaming. 1111R. Ach, das ist das, was normalerweise unter Fast Roaming oder was auch immer. Ja,
das ist wenn und mehr, dass der Klein, besser gesagt, dass die Access Points zu den Händen
miteinander koordinieren. Ja, das ist tatsächlich nice, aber gut, brauche ich nicht. Ich habe
aktuell nur ein Access Point dran. Background Scaling, Load Balancing, OSAS, Force DRCP,
Isolate Wireless from Other Clients. Das will ich haben für ein IoT Netzwerk auf jeden Fall.
Isolate Wireless Klein Traffic from All Hosts on the same WLAN Subnet. Ne, same AP reicht.
Mal gucken. Okay. Ich meine, das WLAN ist eh immer noch aus. Wie stehst du eigentlich
zu OpenWRT und PFSense? Das ist mega nice. Gerade OpenWRT ist richtig pock an Features.
Leider haben sie das mit diesem dynamischen Key noch nicht fertig eingebaut und PFSense
hatte ich auch noch weile, war mir aber alles ein wenig zu Single Point of Failure, was
ich gebaut habe mit meiner fetten Kiste. Also ich hatte OpenSense, ich hatte, stimmt, ich
hatte kein PFSense, ich hatte OpenSense. So, und wie generiere ich jetzt Passwörter für
meine Clients? Close? Show Client Info. Ja, gibt nix, ne? Show Client Info. Show System
Overview. Ah ja, das Ding hat übrigens zwei Interfaces, falls man das braucht. Wo lege
ich denn jetzt? Ah, hier lege ich jetzt Keys Untarget, WLAN, Vodafone, Number to Create,
Generated Dynamic PSCars. Ok, hier kann ich jetzt Passwörter generieren für einzelne
Clients. Ok, was passiert, wenn ich jetzt auf Generate klicke? Wenn das WLAN ist aus,
ich werde jetzt hier nichts leaken. 512, ja, damit sollte ich auskommen. Generate. Dynamic
PSCars. Äh, ok. Und wo sehe ich jetzt das Passwort? To Download Latest Click Here. Seriously,
als CSV? Ernsthaft? Meine WLAN Passwörter als CSV? Na, geiler, man. Stehen da jetzt
die Passwörter im Klartext drinne? Ich bin mir gar nicht so sicher, ob ich das jetzt
aufmachen soll. Egal, ich mach das jetzt auf. Das WLAN ist eh. Discard. Ah, geh weg. Das
WLAN ist eh offen. Äh, nicht offen, ist eh disabled. Ah, hier ist das Passwort jetzt
im Klartext drinne, ok. Aber ohne MAC-Adress, also ohne MAC-Adress heißt das kann jeder
einmalig verwenden oder wie ist das? Keine Ahnung. Das wären jetzt die WLAN Passwörter
für fünf unterschiedliche Geräte, ok. So, das heißt, ich kann jetzt hier sagen, Delete
All, zack und alle widerrufen, Gerät wegschmeißen und keiner mehr Zugriff. So, jetzt muss ich
mir da irgendwie mal ein Passwort rauskopieren. Ohne, dass ihr das seht. Testen wir das doch
mal. Also, Numbers to Create. Aber Moment, kann ich irgendwie auch die Dinger von Hand
vergeben? DPSK-Batch. To Download. Ich kann nämlich fertige Profile uploaden. Example
Profile. Aha. Hier könnte ich jetzt MAC-Adressen von Anfang an hinterlegen. Also, da könnte
ich zum Beispiel sagen, keine Ahnung, das ist Gast, äh, Max oder so, wenn der Typ so
ist. Und dann könnte ich mir dafür was anlegen. Das brauche ich jetzt nicht. Aber wir probieren
es trotzdem mal aus. Keine Ahnung, es gibt jetzt Gast Max und Raspberry Pi. Keine Ahnung.
Raspberry Pi Keller. Da wüsste man sogar wie das Ding heißt. So, Save. Sehe TSV. Leer.
Okay, da würde ich jetzt einen neuen User anlegen. So, das würde jetzt drei User anlegen,
wenn ich das richtig sehe. Also, Upload. Generate. Hä, das funktioniert. Das ist,
das ist nice. Was natürlich cool wäre, wenn ich den PSK mir selbst ausdenken kann, aber
ich glaube nicht, dass es funktioniert. Was eigentlich gar nicht so schlimm ist, weil
so hat man auf jeden Fall sichere Passwörter. Okay, das wären jetzt die Passwörter für
den Access Point. Okay, das ist tatsächlich ganz nice. Das muss man auf jeden Fall so
machen, weil es checkt doch am Ende keiner mehr, wer hier was ist, wenn die einfach Dynamic
Generated heißen. So, weil man es anhand der Mac hier dann zuordnen könnte. So, jetzt
müssen wir es irgendwie ausprobieren. Das heißt, ich muss jetzt ein WLAN, ich muss
jetzt ein Passwort generieren, ohne dass ihr das seht. Chat, ihr müsst jetzt mal kurz
Generate. Ihr müsst jetzt mal kurz ausgeblendet werden. Also, gibt es eine Mac Address Whitelist?
Nee, du kannst es nach Mac Adresse machen oder Dynamisch. Ich probiere es jetzt mal
Dynamisch. So, Display Capture aus. Chat, ihr müsst jetzt mal kurz weg. EPSK, okay.
Alles klar, ich habe mir eins rauskopiert. Und wieder zu. Seht nicht alles. Und wieder
da. So, also jetzt habe ich das Passwort mir rauskopiert von Raspberry Pi, was der jetzt
gleich kriegt. Und dann sagen wir doch jetzt mal, also wir haben jetzt hier DPSK, Generate,
alles mit Mac 0, Passwort sieht man jetzt hier nicht mehr. Also man hat einmalig die
Chance das Passwort zu sehen, sonst sieht man das Passwort nie wieder. Was eigentlich
ganz gut ist, so. So, und jetzt machen wir das WLAN an. Enable. Jetzt gehen wir auf den
Raspberry Pi und sagen, die Namen kannst du editieren, ja. Achso, nee, die später
editieren geht glaube ich nicht. Du kannst sie beim Anlegen editieren. Ja, das ist nicht
so schön. Vielleicht ist es in der neueren Version besser. Wisst ihr, das ist auch was,
wo ich mir durchaus vorstellen kann, ein Kommando Zeilen Tool zu basteln, was das für einen
macht. Das können wir gleich noch probieren. Da müssen wir irgendwie Chrome fernsteuern
oder so. Das wird lustig. Also, Raspberry Pi System, Wireless LAN, SSID, Vodafone, CacWate
und Passwort, Copy Paste. Bam. Finish. Bam. Aha. Und jetzt ist es dynamisch gebunden auf
die IP vom Raspberry Pi, also sprich auf die Mac Adresse, also sprich die erste Mac, also
das erste Gerät, was sich verbindet mit diesem Passwort, dann ist das wohl gelockt, also
sprich jetzt kann ich es wieder löschen anhand der Mac. Das finde ich cool. Das ist sehr
nice. Das ist wirklich cool. Das gefällt mir echt. So, und wenn ich jetzt das probiere
mal aus, ob das funktioniert. Sekunde. Was hat das Ding für eine gekriegt? Ich muss
gerade mal pingen. Das ist der Raspberry Pi. Nutzen das nicht Hotels? Doch, auch. So,
und jetzt sagen wir ihm hier mal Delete. Jetzt sollte ja der Ping ausgehen gleich, hoffe
ich mal. Aber Disable gibt es nicht. Es gibt nur Delete. Disable gibt es nicht. Na gut.
Es kommt kein anderer mit dem Passwort mehr rein und wenn ich es lösche, noch nicht mal
er selbst. Das heißt, ich könnte das Gerät jetzt wegschmeißen. Zack. Selbst wenn du
die Mac Adresse spufst, bringt dir das ja nichts. Weil das Passwort gilt jetzt nicht
mehr. Also du musst das Passwort kennen und die Mac Adresse spufen und ich muss es noch
nicht gelöscht haben. Die Sache ist bloß die, du hast keine Chance das Passwort rauszubekommen,
dass du mein Gerät zufällig im Müll findest. Also eigentlich ist das ziemlich gut durchdacht.
Guck, es funktioniert. Nice. Sehr, sehr nice. Sehr, sehr nice. Das ist genau das was man
haben will für IOT Geräte. Genau das. Clients Connected. Guck hier, da steht er drin. Status
unauthorized. Hier kann man es, also ganz ehrlich, das finde ich, obwohl das erst noch von vor
eineinhalb Jahren ist, hier das Update, was ich bekomme, finde ich das vom Handling her
schon unbedingt besser als den Wi-Fi Controller. Wenn du jetzt neue generierst, werden die dazu
addiert zu der existierenden Liste oder Stelle. Nee, nee, die werden hinzugefügt. Die werden
hinzugefügt. Da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher. Können wir mal ausprobieren. DPSK. DPSK. Keine
Numbers to create. Zwei. Generate. Bam. Zwei Stück generiert. Generate. Zwei. Vier. Ja.
Der edit die neu. Ja. Ja, anders wäre das ja auch komplett useless, Alter. Jetzt wäre
es natürlich noch cool, wenn ich irgendwie, also es wäre zwei Sachen cool, wenn ich das
nicht über eine CSV-Datei machen müsste. Wenn man das irgendwie, wenn ich mir irgendeine
Kommando-Zeilen-Tool dafür bauen könnte. Gibt es GitHub Unleashed API? Gibt es da
sowas schon? Pi Ruckus. Python Klein Ruckus Unleashed. Das ist doch gut. Es ist halt sehr
nichtssagend. Kannst du eine bestehende Liste von Namen her bearbeiten? Nein. Du kannst
importieren mit den Namen, die du haben willst, aber du kannst nachträglich nichts mehr dran
ändern. Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass es daran liegt, wie er den Key errechnet oder
weil sie noch keinen Bock hatten, das zu implementieren. Da wäre jetzt natürlich eine
Root-Shell auf dem Gerät äußerst nice, weil dann könnte ich gucken, in welcher Text-Satei
das Trennchen was von Hand einfügen. Aber gut, kann ja alles haben. Also diese API erschließt
sich mir mal überhaupt gar nicht. Generate, exportieren, bearbeiten, importieren. Ne,
das geht nicht. Äh, das geht nicht. Du kannst, wobei, vielleicht. Ok, wir generaten mal
vier Stück. Generate, so. Download. Ja gut, das würde, ne. Das sind ganz andere, das
sind ganz andere Felder. Ich meine, ich kann es mal ausprobieren. Keck, Keck W1. Wir legen
jetzt Keck W1 bis 4 an. Passphrase 123, 12345, 12345. Das sollte so nicht funktionieren.
WLAN-Voter von MAC-Address. Ne, das wird nicht funktionieren. Ok, Upload. Error. Passphrase.
Is not correct. Ok, das mag er nicht. Ne, kannst du nicht. Bringt dir nichts. Bringt
dir nichts. Das kannst du mit ihm im Controller machen, aber ich will ja keinen Controller
haben. Lass mal original pw. Ok, ok, machen wir. Delete. Generate. Aber das original Passwort
sollte er ja überhaupt nicht, überhaupt nicht kennen. So. Nur die Namen. Ne, das wird nicht
klappen. Sehr wundervoll, wenn das funktioniert. Upload. Nope. Geht nicht. Also du kannst nur
generaten oder uploaden. Oder man macht sich wirklich irgendein Kommando-Zeilen-Tool, was
das für einen anlegt. Es wäre schon cool, wenn man selbst PSKs vergeben könnte. Auf
der anderen Seite, ganz im Ernst, ist es gar nicht so schlecht, dass man es nicht kann,
dann sind die Dinger wenigstens halbwegs sicher an Passwörtern und man kommt gar nicht in
Versuchung 123456 oder so einen Blödsinn zu vergeben. Dass man hier den Namen nicht editieren
kann ist tatsächlich doof. Aber wisst ihr was? Die Version ist auch alt, vielleicht geht
es ja mittlerweile. Kann ja sein. Aber man bekommt sie ja anhand der Mac. Also nachdem
die Mac-Adresse dann gelockt wird, geht auch nicht in der neuen Version, ok. Da kann man
es anhand der Mac-Adresse dann schon erkennen, wer was ist. Es reicht. Also ich finde das
nicht schlecht, das passt schon. Was passiert denn hier im Hintergrund Leute? Mal kurz im
Hintergrund checken, ob man das einfach verskripten kann in der Kommando-Zeile oder mit einem
ferngesteuerten Browser. Alter was passiert denn hier im Hintergrund? Was passiert denn
hier auf einem Klick bei Generate? Was passiert denn auf einem Klick bei Generate? Wow! Alter!
Er macht ja 50 Sachen man! Boah! Embed this. Embed this? Ach das gibt es tatsächlich.
GitHub, das ist ein Web-Server oder wie? Embed this, Web-Apps, Samples. E, ein C++ Web-Server,
und KS. Decrypt X. Alles klar, da weißt du ja Bescheid. Generate. Ok, da macht nur diese
zwei Sachen. DocMD-Comp? Ok, das ist ziemlich Lichtsang, was hier passiert gerade. Weil
ich hätte mir gedacht, vielleicht kann man sich dafür ein kleines Kommando-Zeilentool
basteln, sei es das es im Hintergrund im Browser fernsteuert, dass man nicht Excel-Files, CSVs
hoch und runter laden muss, weil das ist schon abfuck oder? Download, klick hier. Joa, da
lädt er den Kram runter, ok. Save-Batch-PSK-Pilename 05. Ok, das müssen wir jetzt mal ausprobieren.
Das müssen wir jetzt mal testen. Ob? Also das, das merke ich mir mal. Copy, Copy, Will.
So, wenn ich jetzt nochmal neugenerate, das macht man nur einmal. Nö, das macht man
für jeden, für jedes Gerät macht man das einmal. Wenn ich jetzt einen neuen Generate,
dann ist ja die Download-Uhrl anders. Wenn ich einen neuen Generate, ist die Download-Uhrl
ja so? 26? Gilt denn die alte noch? Haha, die alte gilt auch noch! She baited! PSK-User
hier. Das ist History. Oh, es ist immer die letzte Datei. Egal welche Adresse ich eingebe.
Ok, das haben sie schon mal halbwegs sicher gemacht. Na was auch immer. Ja, vielleicht
kann man das irgendwie so einstellen, dass man das ordentlich mit dem Browser fernsteuern
kann. Das gucke ich mir mal offstream an, da hab ich jetzt keinen Nerv mehr für. Ja,
man könnte theoretisch aufzeichnen, was passiert und es dann replayen in irgendeinem Puppeteer,
Chromium oder sonst was. Das muss man tatsächlich mal ausprobieren. Und sei es nur, sei es
nur, dass man einfach irgendwelche Browserklicks simuliert. Du kannst doch 512 generieren und
daraus immer dein Schlüssel für ein neues Gerät nehmen. Ja, das stimmt schon. Die Sache
ist bloß die, wenn du mal Geräte wegschmeißt, dann möchtest du vielleicht neue Schlüssel
einfügen und vielleicht willst du die Dinger ja benennen. Aktuell heißt die Dinger Batch
DPS Car User. Vielleicht will ich denen ja einen gescheiten Namen geben. Und das muss
ich dann bei jedem Gerät einzeln machen. Mit dem Upload von so einer CSV-Datei. Das
müsste ich mir mal angucken, wie man da den Browser fernsteuern kann. Das ist jetzt nichts,
was man akut machen muss. Nein, das ist kein Vouchersystem im Sinne, wie man es kennt,
bei den normalen Vouchers geht es ja darum, du gehst in ein offenes WLAN. Du sagst, ich
will 30 Sekunden join und dann kriegst du eben ein Code. Diesen Code benutzt du aber
nicht als WLAN-Passwort, sondern diesen Code gibst du nachdem du dich im WLAN eingeloggt
hast, dann nochmal bei irgendeiner Portalsite ein. Das funktioniert ein bisschen anders.
Das ist dann mit Captive Portal und Gedöns dabei. Das ist wirklich auf WLAN-Ebene. Genau,
man muss das in der CSV-Liste anpassen und hochladen. Das geht, das geht. Genau, das
funktioniert. Du musst immer die CSV-Liste anpassen einmalig, wenn du ein neues Gerät
zufügst, in dem du ein Name geben willst. Ja, das geht, das kannst du machen. Aber das
ist trotzdem sehr nice, ich überleg mir mal was. Dann mach ich mir irgendwie so ein CLI,
dass das einfach pro, ne, dann mach ich irgendwie so ein CLI, keine Ahnung, nennen wir das
irgendwie CACW.SH und dann kann ich das angeben, keine Ahnung. Name, Raspberry Pi und eventuell
noch Mac, aber Mac kann man standardmäßig leer lassen und dann krieg ich als Antwort
das Passwort. Nein, nur ein CSV mit zwei und morgen mit drei. Jaja, das geht, das kannst
du machen, kannst du machen. Ich will ja CSV gar nicht editieren. Ja, man könnte sich
mit dem Tool dann auch offline die Passwörter ablegen, aber ich bin mir gar nicht so sicher,
ob man die Passwörter wirklich eigentlich offline dann überhaupt ablegen möchte, weil
wenn man das Passwort verliert und das Gerät aus dem WLAN nimmt, dann generiert man sich
ein neues Passwort. Das muss ich mir überlegen, keine Ahnung. Überlegen, muss ich mir überlegen,
wie ich das mache. Weil hier, du hast keine Chance das Passwort wieder jemals rauszubekommen.
Was auch gut so ist. Die richtigen HiIQ Leute würden das wahrscheinlich über irgendeinen
Radioserver machen, das habe ich schon gesehen. Man kann auch zur Authentifizierung irgendeinen
Radioserver nehmen und darüber die PSKs ziehen, das habe ich bei denen auf der Webseite gelesen.
Das ist mir aber eindeutig zu overkill, damit könnte ich dann aber auch Custom Keys machen,
aber da habe ich keinen Bock rauszubekommen, wie das funktioniert. So Leute, schwere Geburt
dank dem Raspberry Pi, der keinen Bock hatte. DPSK Unleashed Script, gibt es da vielleicht
schon was? GitHub. Was hast du in der Guest Access für Optionen? Ich habe jetzt den Access
Point schon ausgeschaltet. Ich weiß nicht mehr, soll ich nochmal einschalten? Ich schalte
nochmal ein, können wir mal gucken. Ich schalte nochmal ein, geht doch schnell. Unleashed.
Gucken wir mal, wann er wieder da ist. In OpenSense geht sowas glaube ich, in OpenSense
kannst du ein Webportal machen, was dich temporär freischaltet, aber sowas wie hier mit den
Custom Passwörtern geht in OpenSense nicht. Und wer doch, würde mich sehr interessieren
wie das dort heißt und wie das geht. Guck mal, GitHub, OpenSense, oder sowas gucken wir
mal. Achso, das ist komplett, MPSK. EPS, das hat da wohl bei OpenSense noch nie einer
zur Sprache gebracht dieses Thema. DPSK. Nö, gibt es nicht. Vielleicht kannst du das
kombinieren mit separaten Netzen für die Gäste benutzen. Ja, du kannst den irgendwie
VLANs zuordnen beim Login dann, das geht. Hat er sich jetzt eine neue IP geholt oder
was? Sekunde, ich muss mal mein DHCP gucken. Hä? Der hat die IP immer noch. Der ist bloß
auch nicht gebootet, der ist nicht so schnell im Booten. Gut, Strom war ja auch komplett
weg. Hostam ist by the way Q-Chat für den Access Point. Alter, was bootet der denn 3
Sekunden, Mann? Anzeige wieder. So, nö, so. Pricked, Leute, pricked. Ah, ich weiß warum
es nicht geht. Ich habe den Switch schon ausgeschaltet. Lull. Der Switch, wo er dran hängt, ist aus.
Ich lecke critical information. Was ist mein Access Point? Das ist ein, der da. Das habe
ich zu rumbasteln gekauft. Ich habe für daheim einen R710 zum benutzen. Okay, Access Point
geht nochmal an. Wie machen die das mit Hotels? Ja, also entweder mit sowas hier in der Richtung
oder was ich öfters in Hotels gesehen habe, ist, dass du halt ein Portal hast, wo du dich
anmelden musst und dann temporär freigeschaltet wirst. Weißt du, du gehst in den offenen
WLAN oder vielleicht auch in eins, wo du die Zugangsdaten bekommst. Unten muss ich aber
noch mal explizit in den Portal freischalten. Was ich mache, jetzt nix mehr, wir sind eigentlich
mehr oder weniger fertig. Ich wollte jetzt bloß nochmal für den Basti nachgucken, was
unter Guest Access steht, wenn der Access Point irgendwann gestartet ist. Da ist er.
Nmap. Jetzt braucht es eine Weile, bis der hochgefahren ist. Was können die besser als
Unify? Boah, habe ich mich heute am Anfang im Stream darüber ausgelassen. Zum Beispiel
können die eigene Passwörter pro Gerät für das gleiche WLAN. Da hat Unify nämlich
keinen Bock drauf, sowas zu implementieren. Darf ich deinen Router mal testen? Hä? Wie
geht's? Vpn oder wie? Nee.
So ist es jetzt um. Ok, weiß gucken wir klar. Alter, eben war das Webinterface da rauf.
Warum ist das Webinterface jetzt wieder zu? Die können sich nicht entscheiden. Webinterface
ist noch nicht auf. Ok, ist noch nicht gestartet das Ding. Dann gucken wir mal kurz hier das
an. Das ist WPA Enterprise, das ist was anderes. Das ist was anderes.
Nee, das ist was anderes. Du kannst ja auch nur ein Passwort angeben.
WPA Key Management Mode würde mich tatsächlich mal interessieren, was dahinter steckt. WPA
Key Management Mode. Opensense. WPA Key Management Mode. Steht dahinter? Was? Alter, da weißt
du überhaupt nicht, was die nicht sagen. Ok, ist es jetzt offen? Jo. Alles klar. Ok,
also was soll ich gucken? Services, Guest Access, das da? Ah, da kannst du wahrscheinlich,
da kannst du solche Pässe generieren. Wenn du ein offenes WLAN hast und möchtest, dass
man dann irgendwie so ein Portal hat. Ja, da kannst du Guest Access generieren. Irgendwelche
Tokens für die. Das ist ja quasi das Klassische, das ist aber
nicht WLAN Passwörter unterschiedlich pro Gerät. Printout. In French. Hauptsache,
das gibt es in Französisch alle. Review. Alles klar. Ok, Guest WLAN. So, so. Nee.
Oh. Leute, reicht fast vier Stunden an gewesen, hat ewig gedauert, weil Kram Amourist Party
Pie nicht funktioniert hat. Geht's auf. Wir sehen uns bis im nächsten Stream. Ich hoffe,
euch hat's gefallen. Bis denn. See you.